hallo ah ich hab mich gemutet omg lol
wenn man schon in twitch emote spricht, dann kann man immer ganz dicht sein
ihr seht irgendwas mit meiner lautstärke
ich glaub die irgendwie spackt die lautstärke rum oder
ich mein
wirds da Mist eingestellt?
ich glaube die lautstärke ist normalerweise
weiß ich nicht wie laut ich sonst immer laber im stream
windows stellt den kram irgendwie immer um
ich lasse es jetzt mal auf 80 mal gucken also wenn es zu laut ist
wenn es zu laut ist dann schmeiß ich wieder weg
der raketen karl, pock alter
pock, jetzt kann ich mal gucken wie laut ist wenn ich sag pock
pock ist viel zu laut
viel zu laut, ich bin lauter als sonst
ja raketen karl, pock, huge
und die sound settings haben sich voll verstell
das muss lauter und das muss leiser
warum stellt windows den kram immer um? ich versteh das nicht
windows logik
so jetzt ist gut
könnte man den discord bot so einstellen, dass er gleich den link zum stream schickt?
bestimmt, aber ich hab den discord bot nicht
eingerichtet, weiß es nicht
muss da patrick oder das ebara oder irgendwer machen
ja danke für die wünsch prime sub
ich muss mal nen emote finden
reload, wo ist es?
das ist ein prime sub, prime sub
krasser shit
die modes haben sich auch verschoben ich weiß nicht was da kaputt ist
voll fail grade
übrigens falls es euch noch nicht aufgefallen ist, es gibt jetzt ein sub badge
der hat ja mcore gestern zusammen gebastelt
das ist die unkreativste sub badge die man überhaupt haben kann, nur mal so angemerkt
es ist einfach der keks
ohne etwas dabei
ich wollte ja noch andere sachen machen, aber ich hab gedacht bevor es jetzt wieder so ewig dauert, mach ich das erstmal rein
mach ich das erstmal rein und dann können wir immer noch gucken
ja genau, dann können wir immer noch gucken ob das passt
besser als dieser default prime stern da, ja das sackt
das sackerino
der stream wahnsinn, weil man stream auch so voll wahnsinnig ist
da muss der xqc angucken, wenn du den stream wahnsinn haben willst
der springt dann mal einfach während dem stream auf seinen stuhl und fliegt aufs maul
wenn ich das machen würde hätte ich mir gleich einen arm gebrochen
oder irgendwie sowas
also ihr müsst jetzt mal in euch gehen
und wir mal sagen
ob ich die lautstärke settings richtig eingestellt habe, ob sich das anhört wie immer
oder ob ich zu laut bin
ich glaube zu leise bin ich nicht
eher bin ich ein tick zu laut
hören tue ich das nicht, weil mein feedback, also dass ich mich selbst höre
das geht über das audio interface, da hab ich ja nichts umgestellt
nur windows stellt den kram immer um
das einzige was ich gemacht hab ist gestern, ich hab overwatch ptr installiert
und ein bisschen meine windows sound settings hochgedreht und schon stimmt die streaming settings nicht mehr
vor kompletter fail
sackt extreme
also leute
overwatch, ja guckt hier mal zum beweis, ich hab es echt installiert
aber das spielen wir jetzt nicht
ich hab gestern zwei runden gespielt
ich hab gestern zwei runden overwatch gespielt, hab festgestellt
dass ich nicht nur schlecht geworden bin, sondern extrem schlecht
und dann hab ich keinen bob mehr gehabt
ich hab sogar geschafft mit
was war das
nepal, ne
lijang tower
mit lucy runterzufallen nehmen
weil ich aus dem spawn, weil ich krass aus dem spawn sliden wollte und dann bin ich
an der
raumschiffwand weiter gesliden und runtergefallen
so richtig bronze, richtig bronze noob
das war vom letzten stream
warum ist das pp-gabot nicht auf, ah weil ich nicht gestartet hab
wer hätte das denken können ich starten
läufts auch nicht
jetzt sieht man auch gleich auf den ersten blick alle
alle
weil die alle so einen keks haben
ja flamehaze, wir haben jetzt subpatches, jetzt kannst du endlich subben
sellout modus aktiviert
ah ihr könnt euch ja mit sicherheit noch an die
paketverfolgungsapp erinnern, die wir programmiert haben, weil ich mein das war vor
letzten stream
haben wir mw2 angeguckt
mw4 angeguckt, ich nenns jetzt mal mw4
ich nenns jetzt mal mw4, weil
weil die benahmung mir jetzt übelst wirr ist
bin free to watch
adblock on, never sub, never donate
free entertainment copypasta, brauchst du jetzt nur noch
läuft das ganze jetzt, ja passt, sehr schön
also mit twitch copypastas macht mir keiner was vor
ich hab mittlerweile einen 800 zeilen text file mit twitch copypastas
wir haben sogar extra einen discord
extra im discord hab ich einen channel gemacht
wo
wo man die besten
von den besten twitch copypastas reinhauen kann
hier, wichtig
und ganz wichtig
running low on cuties, wenn q-chat an ist
wenn q-chat an ist
wer übrigens noch nicht auf dem discord ist und
joinen möchte, ausrufe zeige ich in discord
äh neue ide hattest du nicht immer vs, doch doch ich hab immer noch vs
das ist rider unter linux
ähm
weil wir haben ja dieses
das chat log board
haben wir ja unter linux gebastelt
soll ich euch mal die fortschritte vom parquet tracker zeigen
der ist jetzt huge
huge ähm
beautiful oberfläche
der parquet tracker
allerdings track da zurzeit fake
weil ich ja nur 250 ap abfragen für die hl habe
und die beim programmieren instant weg werden
aber ich zeig dir mal den fall
das soundtrack so
da ist er, da ist er, da hat er die richtige copypasta rausgekommen
never sub, never donated, adblock on, stone, laptop, neighbors wifey, free entertainment
genau die copypasta mein ich
was da los
come on bra
direkt speichern und in discord copypasta channel pasten
wichtig
die muss man konservieren
der knerbeer verstehe ich, der knerbeer hat kein geld, der muss owl subben
dead game subben
warum startest du dein tools eigentlich immer über die e
ja eine gute frage, keine ahnung, eigentlich total bescheuert
total bescheuert, ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn
ergibt wirklich überhaupt keinen sinn
ah
wie du hast jetzt gesubbt und machst noch nicht mal das icon hin, das ist ja noch mehr fail
dead game
Wir haben noch zwei Fragen aus dem letzten Stream offen, und zwar
Wie schätzt du die Nützlichkeit von IT-Consultants ein?
Unterschiedlich nützlich schätze ich dir ein
Zum größten Teil
Also das Wort Consultant hört sich ja so an, als konsultiert man denjenigen zu irgendwas, was man selber nicht kann
Das ist allerdings selten der Fall, meistens nimmt man das einfach, wenn man irgendwelche Arbeitskräfte braucht und gerade keine hat
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, es gab bisher noch keinen Consultant, der mir in den Bereichen, wo ich mich auskenne, was Neues erzählen konnte
Was aber auch okay ist, weil eigentlich würde man einen Consultant dann holen, wenn man vor einem bestimmten Bereich keine Ahnung hat
Also ich schätze die Nützlichkeit nicht allzu hoch ein
Viele Leute machen das halt, also sagen wir so, es gibt zwei Sorten von Consultants
Es gibt einmal die Leute, die Consultant werden, weil sie keine Ahnung haben
Zum Beispiel der unser ehemaliger Special Azubi, das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt im Stream
Der die IHK-Prüfung mit Acha und Krach geschafft hat und im dritten Lehrjahr quasi nichts wusste
Der im dritten Lehrjahr es nicht mal geschafft hat, ein popliches Strukturgramm zu malen, Sinnhaftigkeit sei mal dahingestellt
Ein popliches Strukturgramm zu malen bzw. mir zu erklären, was passiert, wenn Rechner A zu Rechner B einen Ping schickt
Das hat er im dritten Ausbildungsjahr nicht hinbekommen
Da habe ich mir gedacht, gut, das ist jemand, der ist komplett planlos
Und was ist er geworden? Junior Consultant
Easy
Und dann hat man natürlich noch die Sorten Consultants, die sich wirklich auskennen
Und eventuell auch mit den ein oder anderen Sachen, die nicht so gebräuchlich sind, die kann man dann auch wirklich so nennen
DennisTheGamer96
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da jetzt so stolz drauf sein kann, dass man keine Ahnung hat
Allerdings, es gibt ja auch Leute, die ich zitiere
Never sub, never donated, adblock, onstone, laptop, neighbors wife, a free entertainment machen, wenn man sich zu der Gruppe zählen will, das ist natürlich überhaupt kein Problem
Jetzt kommen wir in die Coffee Pasta
Cute Chat
Genau, soviel zu IT Consultants
Und dann haben wir noch eine Frage von Anima Vestra
Moin Max, hast du eigentlich schon mal selbst Games programmiert, zum Beispiel mit Unity?
Nein, ich habe noch nie Games programmiert und auch noch nicht mit Unity
Das liegt hauptsächlich daran, dass ich überhaupt keine Game Ideen habe
Ja, wenn ich vielleicht irgendwelche coolen Ideen, irgendwelche Sinnvollen...
Die Musik ist ein bisschen leise, könnten wir jetzt wieder ein bisschen lauter machen, die weiß nicht so genau, was sie will
Ja, jetzt ist es besser
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ideen, was Games anbelangt
Deswegen, wenn ich eine gute Idee hätte, würde ich mir vielleicht es auch mal überlegen, aber ich bin da sehr unkreativ
Früher, wo ich noch kleiner war, habe ich mir immer gedacht, ich würde gerne mal so ein eigenes Zelda-Style RPG machen, weil ich hatte übelste Zelda-Fan
Aber jetzt, im Nachhinein, wüsste ich gar nicht, was ich da machen sollte, was noch nicht schon mal gemacht wurde
Und mir ist auch klar geworden, dass man Games nicht programmiert in dem Sinn
Also, zu einem Game gehört noch viel, viel mehr dazu
Da ist die Logik, die man programmiert, ein Teil von
Aber alles andere, was Sound, Animation und Grafik angeht, bin ich der totale Flasche drin
Also, ich könnte den Teil programmieren, aber ich bräuchte auf jeden Fall irgendjemand, der das andere kann
Ein Shooter ohne Waffen, ja
So ein Asset-Flip-Unity-Game
Oder, nee, noch besser
So ein Asset-Flip-Unreal-Game
Einfach in Unreal Store gehen, eine Map runterladen und ein paar Häuser draufstellen und dann Easy Stream Queerlight
Wenn du auf Steam kriegst, dann mittlerweile alles
Ein Pong-Spiel
Ich hab noch kein Game programmiert
Ich hab noch einer, das Stampf-Game von Alt-R4-Games
Das Stampf in Anführungsgeräten
Game
Das hab ich damals gebastelt, aber das ist kein Game
Das besteht aus zwei Bildern
Und das Bild wechselt auf Tastendruck
Also, das ist kein Game
Nein, ich hab noch kein Game programmiert
Wenn du schon beim Thema bist, wie funktioniert Ping eigentlich?
Muss da für irgendein Port offen sein?
Basiert das auf TCP oder UDP?
Weder noch, das ist ICMP, nennt sich das Ganze
Die Apfel-Nudel ist auch da
Das ist weder TCP oder UDP, das ist ICMP
Und ICMP ist genau für solche Control-Messages gedacht
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was das für ein ICMP-Type ist
Ich glaub 22 und 23 oder sowas?
Nee, 8
0 und 8
Okay, nicht 22, 23, was auch immer
Was war denn 22, 23? Achso, SSH war 22 und 23
Nee, warte mal
23 SMTP, oder?
Oder?
Ach, warum soll man sich so einen Blödsinn merken?
22 ist auf jeden Fall SSH
Oder war 23 Telnet?
Nee, 25 SMTP
Telnet-Port
Was, was?
23, ja 23 war Telnet
Ah, das ist...
Ein paar Sachen bleiben da noch hängen
Ja, also damit ist das denk ich mal beantwortet
Wie gesagt, das ist ICMP, das ist ein eigenes Protokoll
Das ist weder TCP noch UDP
Und das musst du in deiner Firewall genauso freischalten
Wie alles andere
Aber wenn ping erlaubt sein soll, musst du einfach ICMP erlauben
Und dann funktioniert das Ganze
Nach 3 Monaten hab ich noch Zeit
Weil, ich hab jetzt erstmal einen Sub-Batch reingemacht
Damit überhaupt was drinne ist
Ich werd's wahrscheinlich so machen, entweder mach ich das wirklich mit den Disketten
Oder nicht mit den Disketten, mit den Minions
Dass wir die in verschiedenen Farben machen
So von Bronze, Gold, Platinum
Irgendwie müsste das auch immer größer werden
Oder was halt auch cool wäre, wenn man unterschiedliche Hardware-Teile hätte
Also, ein Monat ist irgendwie eine Diskette
2 Monate ist dann irgendwie, 3 Monate ist dann irgendwie
6 Monate ist dann irgendwie
Irgendwie sowas
Oder aber halt eine Diskette in unterschiedlichen Farben
Oder in unterschiedlichen Farben
Oder in unterschiedlichen
Von der Bronze-Diskette bis zur Platin-Diskette
Oder den Keks in Schwarz-Weiß, den Keks in Gold
Irgendwas
Ich bin da, wie gesagt, ich bin da echt nicht so sonderlich kreativ, was das angeht
Genau, 12 Monate gibt's da eine NVMe SSD
3 Monate Zip Drive
Zip Drive, kennt ihr das überhaupt noch?
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Die Dinger hier
Ja
Die Teile
Das Teil da, Zip Drive
Zip Drive
3 Drives in einem
Expand your Hard-Drive-Capacity
With unlimited
Unlimited Capacity, 100 MB
Krass ey
Unlimited
Nice, nice, nice, nice
Ich glaube, jeder, der zur damaligen Zeit
Schon aktiv war und einen Computer hatte, der hatte da ein bisschen später auch ein CD-Laufwerk
Und danach einen RW-CD-Brenner
Also wo man auch wieder beschreibbare CDs reinmachen kann
Und jeder
Und ich glaube wirklich jeder ist damals auf die Idee gekommen
Kann man nicht, dass die RW-CD als Festplattenersatz benutzen
Es gab ja Programme, die das gemacht haben
Also da konntest du quasi dein RW-CD-Laufwerk so einbinden
Dass es quasi für Windows ausgeschaut hat wie eine Festplatte
Problem ist halt, dass das unendlich langsam ist
Zugriffszeiten und Schreibzeit auf Doom
Sind das gewesen
Aber es hat jeder ausprobiert, es hat jeder ausprobiert
Weil zu einer Zeit, wo du irgendwie eine Gig Festplattenspeicher hattest
Oder zwei Gig Festplattenspeicher
Da war halt so mal eine 650 MB CD
Oder was ist die Standard-CD-Audio-Länge 74 Minuten, gell?
74 Minuten
Oder 64 Minuten
Oder 72 Minuten
Ach ja, weil es da gerade steht
Wisst ihr warum auf die, jetzt machen wir mal cool Story Mugs
Wisst ihr warum die ursprüngliche CD 74 Minuten hatte?
Gut, ich meine, wenn ich das jetzt so sage, ist blöd, man kann mal nachgucken
Das war, weil ich glaube Sony
Sony war damals der Meinung, sie müssten irgendeine Symphonie von Beethoven veröffentlichen auf der ersten CD
Und die war halt nun mal so lang, komplett
Deswegen ist die erste Audio-CD 74 Minuten
Passt da drauf
Classic
Musik
CD
Beethoven
Ja
Dauert 74 Minuten, genau, das ist das, was auf die CD gepackt haben
Big Brain
Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid, ne?
Warum ist denn die Musik jetzt auf einmal so laut?
Ich mag das nicht, wenn Streams
Zwischendrin
Musik
Das ändern
Kann ja was anderes
Ja, ich gucke immer, dass die Musik hier sich so, so unter, unter der Hälfte ungefähr abspielt, dass man das ordentlich raushört
Fakt
Musik
Da grause ich alles, ja
Ja, das kann man im Hintergrund laufen lassen, so
Der Informatiker Anlasscore ist am Start, POG
Ja, ich zeige euch mal die neue Version von meinem Versandtracker
Der ist jetzt ein bisschen advanceder geworden, ich hab da nämlich gestern auch ein bisschen dran rumgebaut
Am Sonntag, und zwar, ich starte das ganze Ding jetzt mal
Dann ihr sehen, wie poggers das mittler ist, ich hoffe, er kackt jetzt nicht ab
Ja
Ach, das ist Absicht, das ist Absicht, das ist eine Exception, die werfe ich, das ist Absicht, ja, hier da
Dotnet wirft keine Exception, in der Blob drinnen steht, das ist von mir
Das ist zum Testen, dass es nicht abkackt, wenn eine Exception wirft, wenn ich eine Exception werfe
Ich hab ein bisschen umgebaut ohne euch, ne, ich hab nicht umgebaut, ich hab ein bisschen im Webinterface rumgeschraubt, ein paar Sachen gemacht, also passt mal auf
Ähm, wir starten das jetzt mal
Wartet sich das jetzt nicht
Achso, weil wir Visual Studio nicht aufhaben, äh, Visual Studio Code und wir hier noch über den Dev-Server gehen
Den brauchen wir jetzt eh gleich, also können wir ruhig, äh
Den Dev-Server starten und darüber machen das Ganze
So, also
An der Tabelle muss man auch ein bisschen arbeiten, ja
Lustigerweise, ich hab's mir, ich hab's mir nur so angeguckt und so sieht das echt ganz gut aus, ja
Also, was wir jetzt da haben ist
Ich mach mal Fullscreen, Fullscreen siehts, siehts
Das muss man ein bisschen, bisschen schlank machen, ich glaub die Tabelle brauchen wir eh nicht und hier oben das kommt dann auch in die Leiste
Aber guck mal, also wir haben jetzt schon mal wieder einmal, was natürlich ganz, ganz tolle ist, ne, Dark, Dark und äh
Light-Theme, das braucht man
Äh, Beat-Protikon auf meinem Kanal, aber wann, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich brauch erst mal überhaupt ein ordentliches Konzept dahinter
So, ähm
Wir haben ein Dark und Light-Theme, ganz wichtig, ich mach mal kurz das Teuch da oben weg, das irritiert
Ähm
Weg hier
So, jetzt ist es doch viel schöner
Splitten wir das mal, so
Ähm
So, und ihr seht es hier schon, man kann es jetzt ausklappen
Also, du hast jetzt hier drinnen stehen, aktuell was für ein Provider das ist, also was für ein, was für ein Paket Versand tut
Ähm
Dann hast du hier oben die, die Tracking-Nummer drinstehen und wenn du draufklickst, du siehst immer den aktuellsten Stand vom Paket
Hier hat er noch nichts abgerufen, ja da ist es da, ne, du hast das passende Icon dazu
Die kamen, die Sub-Batches kamen vor 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten, bevor ich den Stream angemacht hab und jetzt kommt's, wenn man hier draufklickt, ist richtig huge
Du kriegst hier angezeigt, die History von deinem Paket
Also was er von DHL abgerufen hat hier
Das ist doch nice, oder?
Wenn du hier unten draufklickst, kriegst du von dem Paket angezeigt
Wenn du da draufklickst, kriegst du von dem Paket angezeigt
Wenn du da draufklickst, hat er nichts
Huge, ja
Übrigens alles ist Fake-Tracking-Nummer, die gibt's
Äh, die gibt's nicht, die gibt's nicht, die zwei gibt's
Ne, die, die gibt's
Ob die zwei gibt's?
Zwei Stück gibt's auf jeden Fall
Da krieg ich einen Namenboss
Ähm, man sollte den Paketen auch Namen geben können, ja ich hab mir das eh überlegt
Die, ähm
Die...
Tabelle ist eh relativ sinnlos, ich hab mir gedacht, wir können das nämlich so machen
Dass, dass man hier neben einfach die Buttons hat für löschen und editieren
Und wenn man den Edit-Button drückt, kann man auch irgendwie so einen Comment hinzu...
Genau
Der Name hin ist schwierig, ich hab ja keine Ahnung, was für ein Paket ist
Ich hab hier nur die Dummer, ich weiß ja nicht, ob's von Amazon ist oder sowas
Tommy sagt, ohne irgendwie beleidigend zu sein, aber Anzeige direkt
Bannen, Alter
Äh, welchen Vorteil hat es, äh, dass zu den einfachen Paketverfolgungen benutzen, die es schon mehrfach gibt
Das hat mehrere Vorteile
Ähm, ich glaub ich hab's mal irgendwann so im Stream erklärt, was das Ganze eigentlich geben soll, wenn's fertig ist
Erstens hast du alle Anbieter in Deutschland inklusive Amazon auf einen Blick
Und Amazon können die wenigsten dieser komischen Ganzen, also der ganzen Paketverfolgungs-Apps
Ähm
Dann hast du Integration in deine Heimautomatisierung
Also sprich, du kannst da auch drauf reagieren, wenn ein Paket anrückt
Da kannst du nach, kannst du irgendwie was auch immer damit machen, du weißt das
Ähm, du kriegst, du kannst dir ne Benachrichtigung schicken lassen, wenn dein Paket ankommt, egal vor welchem Anbieter
Und was für Benachrichtigungs-Sachen wir da einbauen, müssen wir mal gucken, ob Discord oder, oder Discord
MQTT, all möglichen Sachen
Und der eigentliche Knackpunkt, oder der eigentliche Witz an der Sache ist ja, dass es dein E-Mail-Postfach scant, was du einträgst
Nach neuen Tracking-Nummern
Das heißt, du musst die Tracking-Nummer gar nicht von Hand hinzufügen
Du, ähm, kriegst ne Mail vom Shop geschickt
Der dir dann sagt, ihre Sendung wurde verschickt
Das klingt ehrlich gesagt ziemlich nach Aftership
So ein bisschen, es gibt ein paar Anbieter, die sowas schon machen, ja
Es gibt ein paar Anbieter, die sowas schon machen, aber die kosten in der Regel alle Geld
Ähm, und, man muss seine E-Mail weiterleiten
An Leute, die man nicht kennt
Ne, du weißt die, du weißt doch, du weißt das gar nicht
Also, was man machen könnte ist
Was man machen könnte ist
Wenn man hinzufügt
Übrigens, falls das jemand jetzt, die letzte Minute wäre nice, wenn das jemand klippen könnte
Dann könnten wir das nämlich nehmen
Ähm, dann könnten wir das nämlich nehmen für die Erklärung, wenn das wieder einer fragt
Ne, wieso Tobi, du kannst es selbst, du kannst es doch bei dir laufen lassen
Also, es ist doch ein Unterschied, ob du deine E-Mail zu irgendeinem Anbieter schickst
Wo du das quasi nur bei dem verwenden kannst
Also, quasi, wenn du nur bei dem
Deinen Cloud-Service verwenden kannst
Oder, ähm, wenn du das nur bei dem verwenden kannst
Wo du dann deinen Cloud-Service verwenden kannst
Oder, ob du das bei dir laufen lassen kannst
Ich dachte, es gibt doch lokale Programme, keine Ahnung
Ich mein, Paket Tracker ist jetzt nichts sonderlich äh, ausgefallenes in dem Sinn
Genau, und außerdem lernt man was beim Selbstbasteln
Ja, also was man machen könnte mit der Nummer ist
Ähm, wenn man das hinzufügt
Oder, beziehungsweise, ich weiß ja an der Stelle nicht
Welche Nummer was ist, ja
Also, in der Senderverfolgung kriege ich das nicht mit
Guck mal hier, in der Senderverfolgung steht es ja nicht drin
Also, in der Senderverfolgung steht sowas drin, wie
Äh, kommt aus Deutschland, geht nach Deutschland
Wiegt so und so viel
Und die Zwischenstation mit Adresse
So, was man jetzt machen könnte ist
Ähm, Api-Key liegt, ja ich weiß
Der Api-Key haben wir zusammen live im Stream erstellt
Da gibt es nichts zu leaken
Webhooks, jaja, kann man
Kann man alles einbauen, das ist ja das Schöne da dran
Ähm, zeig mal wie du das Dropdown gemacht hast, kann ich gleich machen
Ach, nicht die hohe JavaScript-Kunst, die ich da fabriziert habe
Also, was wir machen können wegen der Tracking-Nummer
Es gibt ja zwei Varianten, wie man eine Tracking-Nummer in das Programm kriegt
Und zwar einmal von Hand eintragen
Dann kann man ja einen Kommentar dazu posten
Also, das heißt, das können wir gleich mal hier reinschreiben schon
Dass wir sagen, wir brauchen hier noch
Ups, machen wir mal aus
Das andere zeige ich gleich, äh, Joike
Also, das heißt, wir brauchen schon mal was für eine Tracking-Nummer
Wir brauchen schon mal was für
Hier, Comment
Was nu?
Da musst du unbedingt jetzt oben rüben, da rüber ins Fenster aus
Welchen Gründen auch
Immer
Ähm, wir brauchen sowas wie einen Comment
Das könnte man dann eingeben, wenn man
Wenn man das Ding anlegt
So, und sollte er den Kram aus der E-Mail oder woanders rausfischen
Die Tracking-Nummer, dann könnte man den Absender der E-Mail reinschreiben
In das Comment
Das wäre doch mal was
Wenn er beispielsweise das E-Mail-Postfach durchsucht
Und feststellt, aha, es gibt eine neue Tracking-Nummer
Und das ist eine Tracking-Nummer für, sagen wir, DHL
Dann merkt er sich die Tracking-Nummer
Und im Kommentarfeld, das kann man dann nachher noch ändern
Ist ja okay, wenn man das von Hand anpassen will
Und man könnte in das Comment, könnte man dann quasi
Entweder dann Teil aus dem Betreff von der E-Mail nehmen
Oder den Absender
Wahrscheinlich ist die Absender-Domain das Interessanteste
Die Absender-Domain dürfte das Interessanteste sein
Weil die Absender-Domain ist immer so, quasi Amazon.com
Oder bei irgendeinem Online-Shop dann halt, keine Ahnung
Plumen 2000, irgendwas
Oder Alternate oder sowas
Als Domain
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee, ja
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch, das kann man echt machen
Jetzt zeige ich mal, wie ich das Dropdown gemacht habe, also
Das Dropdown funktioniert folgendermaßen
Erstmal wieder starten
Also wenn man jetzt hier draufklickt
Dann kommt hier so ein Dropdown zu der jeweiligen Sendung
Was da als Status drin ist
Und, mal hier fort
Wie ich das gemacht habe, ist
Die jeweilige Tabelle, die Zelle hier von der Tabelle hat ein Click-Event
Und wenn ich da draufklicke
Ruft es die Funktion, die da draufklicke
Und dann geht es weiter
Und wenn ich da draufklicke, ruft es die Funktion auf
Die hier heißt Expand
Und übergibt die aktuellen Infos
Was das halt für ein Paket ist
Expand macht nicht sonderlich viel
Außer es zu setzen und beim nächsten Klick wieder zu löschen
Und er guckt einfach nach
Wenn das das Feld ist, wo ich reingeklickt habe
Dann gibt er einfach hier die komplette History aus
Filter History
Filter History guckt
Ist das das Feld, was ich angeklickt habe
Dann render ich die komplette History an der Stelle
Ist das das Feld
Ist es ein anderes Feld
Dann render ich nur den letzten Eintrag von der History
Also das ist recht einfach
Wann hast du das alles gemacht?
Gestern
Es ist ja nur ein bisschen CSS Spielerei im Endeffekt
Die Infos waren ja alle schon da
Ja
ViewEqual
Hat das das beantwortet oder willst du es noch ein bisschen genauer wissen?
Kannst du das ruhig noch mal ein bisschen genauer angucken
Wie hast du das mit dem Dark Mode gemacht?
Ist das eine Funktion von View?
Ne, das ist CSS Variable
Das ist jetzt was Neues da
Kannst du hier oben eine Klasse definieren
Light Mode, Dark Mode, wie die heißt ist egal
Kannst du auch Omega Lul Mode und Hyper Lul Mode nennen
Da definierst du halt deine Variablen drinne
Hier Background hat das da
Wenn es Light Mode ist, ist Background das da
Wenn das da
Und dann stellst du hier bei deiner App
Bei deinem Root Element stellst du ein als Klasse
Das ist jetzt View Syntax, aber das kannst du auch mit normalem JavaScript machen
Da stellst du einfach ein bei deinem Root Element
Wenn Dark Mode gesetzt ist, dann weist dem Ding die Klasse Dark Mode zu
Wenn nicht Dark Mode gesetzt ist, dann weist dem Ding die Klasse Light Mode zu
Und dann machst du den Knopf, wo du das zwischendrin umschaltest
Und der Rest macht CSS, weil guck an jeder Stelle, wo ich hier irgendwelche Farben bei CSS verwende
Habe ich jetzt einfach hier als Variable drinne, dementsprechend nimmt er jedes Mal
Je nachdem was das Root Element für eine Klasse hat
Und ich muss doch ehrlich sagen, ich finde Light sieht fast noch besser aus
So und das müssen wir jetzt allerdings da oben irgendwie reinhauen, weil das sieht kacke aus, wenn das da oben so rumhängt
Das Light ist tatsächlich recht dezent das Light, dadurch dass es grau ist
Man kann natürlich immer noch löschen das Zeug, man sieht hier wann zuletzt geupdatet wurde
Wie gesagt, aktuell mache ich so, ich schreibe einfach beim Start ein paar Fakewerte rein
Weil ich ja mit dem Tracker für DHL bloß 250 Aufrufe am Tag habe
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass UPS Hermes und, ne Hermes hat gar keine AP
Dass UPS und DPD auch nicht viel mehr Aufrufe zulassen
Schleppmäßig über ihre AP als eben 250
Die DHL-AP erlaubt mehr, da muss man sich aber registrieren und anmelden mit seiner App und sowas
Mach ich vielleicht mal wenn das Ding dann soweit fertig ist
Ich finde den eigentlich den stylischen Farbverlauf von Orange zu Grün im Hintergrund von den Icon
250 Aufrufe am Tag reicht doch für eine einzelne Person, ja die Sache ist bloß nie
Wenn das dann mehr als einer benutzt, dann reicht das relativ schnell nicht
Und normalerweise sagt man ja man sollte keine AP Keys mit ausliefern
Allerdings in dem Fall ist halt so, es hat keiner Bock sich erstmal 4 AP Keys zu erstellen
Damit er das benutzen kann, deswegen haben wir ja auch den Backup Tracker, den wir abfragen
Das heißt wenn die AP Keys irgendwie aufgebraucht sind oder rumspacken oder einer keinen Bock hat sich einen eigenen AP Key zu generieren
Dann kann er den Backup Tracker nehmen
Ja das ist nicht so einfach, das ist ziemlich ziemlicher CSS Hack, dass der Strich da im Hintergrund überhaupt funktioniert
Der 0x15 User ist zu blöd sich den AP Key zu generieren
Wenn du den Leuten sagst, geh mal hier auf DHL Seite ins Entwicklerportal, mach dir einen AP Key, geh mal bei UPS einen AP Key machen
Das checkt keiner
Ich habe mir schon überlegt, wie ich es irgendwie machen könnte, dass ich einen AP Key mit ausliefer
Ob ich den da irgendwie verschlüsselt rein encode oder so, keine Ahnung
Es geht mir gar nicht so sehr darum, dass den jemand rauskriegt, sondern dass die meisten Anbieter sagen, man darf den AP Key nicht im Klartext ausliefern
Deswegen werde ich den wahrscheinlich so fake-mäßig verschlüsselt einbauen und da kann keiner sagen, ich liefere es im Klartext aus
So ungefähr habe ich mir das auch vorgestellt, wenn das Ding fertig ist, registriere ich mich einmal bei UPS, DPD, DHL, Hermes und Döns
Mache mir den größten kostenlosen Developer Account, da sind wahrscheinlich 1000 Abfragen am Tag
Den liefere ich dann halt verschlüsselt mit aus
Wie gesagt, man darf ihn halt meistens nicht im Klartext reinschreiben
Und wenn das halt aufgebraucht ist, dann ist es aufgebraucht
Allerdings muss man sagen, es dürfte sich in Grenzen halten, weil ich sage mal so, wenn man den Abfrageintervall auf eine Stunde macht
Da können das trotzdem ein paar Leute verwenden am Tag, bis das aufgebraucht ist
Wo ist denn das ein CSS-Hack? Ich finde das ist schon ein ziemlicher CSS-Hack, dass man da mit einer Linie in den Hintergrund mal da
Ich finde das nicht so offensichtlich, wie das geht, was da hier im Hintergrund
Also so viel zum Versand-Tracker
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was wir heute machen
Also ich hätte ein paar Sachen zu auswählen, was wir machen können, vielleicht mache ich einfach auch alles davon
Warte mal, wo habe ich mein Text-Datei?
Kannst du ja Community-Load-Balancing einbauen?
Ich weiß nicht, was für dich genau Community...
Ja, das habe ich hier, guck, da ist er
Ich weiß nicht genau, was du meinst... Ah, Stack-Overflow-Survey, hast du mal einen Link?
Ja, das gucken wir uns an, das wollte ich mir eh noch angucken
Kannst du ja Community-Load-Balancing einbauen, was meinst du damit?
Also was ich mir überlegt habe ist, wir liefern einfach nicht ein APK mit, sondern
Wir registrieren uns einfach mit 10 Fake-E-Mails und machen ein APK
Ja, okay, das ist schon ein bisschen komplizierter
Was man machen könnte ist, was ich mir auch schon überlegt habe ist
Ja gut, aber Creed-Games-OA, da müsste ich die Request-Proxy, da habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf
Oder aber ich mache so, dass mein Programm beim Start von meinem Server einen APK abfragt, der noch gültig ist
Und den dann halt im Speicher behält bis zum Neustart
Sowas in der Richtung, muss ich mir mal Gedanken zu machen
Machst du auch GLS, TNT, die ganzen Firmen rein? Wenn die eine ordentliche API dafür haben, kann ich das machen?
Bisher habe ich bloß so die üblichen Verdächtigen geplant, weil ich es halt selbst verwenden will
Für meine Pakete zu tracken, die von Amazon oder von Alternate oder so kommen
Stimmt, wir wollten uns das Stack-Overflow-Server ein
Jetzt, da habe ich ganz vergessen
Endlich Feierabend, Lel, Lel ist total out, das sagt man immer
Ist genauso wie man nicht mehr Alter sagt oder Alda oder Alda, sondern Digga sagt man auch nicht mehr
Oder Digga, Digga, habe jetzt gehört man sagt Bruder sagt man jetzt
Aber Bruder kann man doch überhaupt nicht cool aussprechen, oder?
Mein Alda kann man allerdings noch Alda sagen oder Alda oder irgendwie sowas
Digga oder, aber wie sagst du Bruder?
Brudi, Brudi, nicht Brudi, auf Ehre Brudi, nicht Bruder
Bruh, Bro
Ah, das ist mir zu dumm
Ich kann noch nicht zu Leuten, die ich kennen noch nie gesehen habe, kann ich noch nicht sagen, ey Bruder
Das hat sich doch total angeblieben, alle
Auf Ehre
Bruder auch nie
Ich weiß nicht, das hört sich irgendwie
Ich wünsche das blöd an
Come on, bruh
Naja, okay, also wir wollten uns das Stack Overflow Umfrage 2019 angucken
Die Entwickler Umfrage 2019
So ein bisschen größer machen, dass man sieht
Also was haben sie mit der Umfragt
Also was die ja jedes Jahr machen ist ja so nach dem Motto
Was sind die Programmiersprachen, mit denen ihr arbeitet und
Was sind die Programmiersprachen und Technik, die euch gefällt
Mal gucken, ob die, ob die
In den letzten Jahren haben sie dann auch noch ein paar Umfragen gehabt irgendwie
Weibliche Entwickler, männliche Entwickler und sowas
Mal gucken, ob sie das dieses Jahr ausgebaut haben
Wenn ich da muss ich wieder aufpassen, wenn ich jetzt das falsche sage
Falsche sagen, kommen wieder die Feministen und regen sich auf
Ist instant die Anzeige raus
Yo, Fellow Kids, Bruder, yo
Das klingt ja so was von hängen geblieben
Das kann ich nicht ernsthaft im Stream sagen
Ich kann viel Blödsinn im Stream erzählen, aber das ist so fremd Schilm
Direkt mal ein Kartoss, ja
Gibt es eigentlich fürs Deckover noch einen Dark Mode
Dark Mode
Was, nicht das, wo meine Trojaner eingebaut war
Da war doch was
Da war doch mal was
Ja genau, ach nee
Die haben irgendwelche Tracking Software eingebaut, das war's
Moin Patrick, das war's, die haben es aus dem Store entfernt
Weil die irgendwelche Sachen getrackt haben
Das installiere ich mir nicht mehr
Die haben es, die haben es verkackt
Das ist so geil, ne
Diese Statements, diese Statements sind immer so geil
Es wurde aus dem Store entfernt wegen Bedenken, was Privatsphäre angeht
Und der erste Satz ist
We care about your privacy
Das klingt immer so toll
Das ist der Motto, wir haben alle unsere Benutzer verarscht und dann kommt als Antwort dann immer sowas wie
Benutzerzufriedenheit ist unser höchstes Ziel
Dark Reader, macht wirklich alle Seiten dark
Was sagst du hier, Dark Reader, willst du gebannt werden oder was?
Anzeige ist raus, gibt's nicht hier
Das war typischer Twitch Blödsinn
Night Eye App
Dark Mode Extension, protect your eyes
Ach das, mal angucken
Sub Emote, ja gibt's jetzt
Keine Emotes, keine Subscriber
Oder wie das Twitch auf Deutsch nennt
Ein Abonnenten treue Abzeichen
Okay, wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Okay, ich installiere mir das jetzt, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert
Add Extension
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was die Extension für eine
Wir removeen das mal kurz
Ich hab gar nicht geguckt, was die Extension von mir will
Read and change all your data on the website you visit
Ach easy, das birgt ja überhaupt keine Gefahren
Oh, Subscriber
Twitch Prime
Wen ham man da?
Ach du Scheiße
Max, Max Exe
Verliedspeaker Max, schreibweise
Max Exe, Poggers, Dankeschön Twitch Prime
Nice, nice, nice
Subscriber
Aber okay, guck mal, die Seite sieht doch ganz hübsch aus, Dark
Moment, das kostet was?
Und wie kann ich jetzt sagen, ich will es für diese Webseite nicht aktivieren
Ein Streamer der mein Name ist
Bin LeadSpeak erprobt
Kann man das jetzt, kann man das hier ausschalten, hier oben?
Also hat man das jetzt aus?
Ah, da unten ist so ein ganz fetter Knopf
Moment, war das Bild schon immer so?
Ja okay, das Bild war schon immer so dunkel
Also ich muss sagen
Ich muss sagen, das sieht ganz gut aus, wie das Addon das macht
Und lesbar
Warum die jetzt, warum wollen die Geld dafür haben?
Ist das hier dim?
Ach cool
Zu light
Das ist hier, dass man abends das mehr Gelb hat
Find ich nice
Und warum soll man das jetzt, expires?
Warum soll man das jetzt kaufen?
Warum soll man das jetzt genau kaufen?
Activate
Warum soll man das kaufen?
Oh, Subscribers, haben wir wieder
Der Knäherbär, ja erstmal auf und auf und an subscribt, den Max subscribt, so mag ich das
Nice
Ja wir kaufen hier keine Addons, sag doch, free entertainment, never sub, add block on
Wen haben wir jetzt noch hier?
Schniedelwutz
Bist du verwandt mit Tiger Woods?
War schlecht
Weil Tiger Woods hat es mit seinem Schniedelwutz ja auch ein bisschen übertrieben
Ich gehe, keine Witze mehr
Kaufen
Warum soll man das kaufen, ok was hat der Darkreader?
Darkreader, Darkreader Chrome
Chrome
Die sprechen eigentlich Japaner Google Chrome aus, die sprechen das doch bestimmt Chrome oder so aus
Die mögen doch so Vokale am Ende
Extensions, ok dann machen wir jetzt mal den
den da wieder aus, ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken
Night Eye, ich muss erstmal schauen, warum
Warum die Geld wollen, das habe ich noch nicht genau gecheckt
Price
Kann man es denn kaufen überhaupt?
Warum wollen die Geld?
Forever free plan
Before going night fee
Night Eye Pro
Die sollten mal genauer erklären, was das ausmacht, also warum man sich Pro kaufen sollte
So genau checken, hier
How to now install Get 3 Monster Flyer April
Wie das ist
Das kriege ich schon mit der kostenlosen Extension dann auch
Ok Darkreader probiere ich jetzt mal aus, Darkreader
Darkreader Chrome
Add
Change and read all your data
Der ist langsamer gefühlt
Der ist langsamer als der andere
Ansonsten sehe ich jetzt gar nicht so viel Unterschied ehrlich gesagt
Was nach 3 Monaten funktioniert das nur auf 5 Webseiten
Egal, wir haben jetzt ewig lang rumgebastelt mit komischen Chrome Extensions
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz nice
Wie schaltet man den aus?
Off
Am
On
Sehr schön
Also gucken wir uns mal die aktuelle Stack Overflow Entwicklerumfrage an
Warum bin ich schon eine Stunde on?
Was?
Warum?
Kommt mir gar nicht so lang vor
Na klar lass mich vom Chat ablenken immer
Ok also was haben sie denn umgefragt oder was gab es ein neues umgefragt?
Blablabla
DevOps Specialists inside reliability
Engineers sind am höchsten bezahlt das ist gut für mich
Das ist gut für mich
Da freue ich mich
Da müssen wir eigentlich gleich mal ein paar Job Angebote nachher wieder angucken
Ok Blablabla Developer Roles
Also wie verteilt sich das ganze?
Developer Types also 51% ich gehe mal davon an dass man mehrere Sachen ankreuzen durfte
Weil ansonsten sind wir über 100% das ergibt ja irgendwie einen Sinn
Also man durfte wahrscheinlich mehrere Sachen ankreuzen
Also es sagen 51% 52% sind Full Stack 50 Backend 32 Frontend
Ja also ich würde mich auch viel eher dazu zählen als Frontend
Ich meine wie gesagt habt ihr ja hier gesehen ich kriege ein bisschen was gebacken
Frontend JavaScript mit
Ich hab nichts gesagt warum hat sich das denn jetzt verschoben
Hab ich kaputt gemacht
Man darf die Seite bloß nicht zu groß machen
Sobald man die Seite zu groß macht
Das ist kein Bug das ist einfach nur responsive
Alles absicht
Ist das kaputt
Ja also ich kriege ein bisschen was Frontend mäßig gebacken
Aber ich bin weit davon entfernt der übelste CSS und HTML CSS Pro zu sein
Also ich würde mich auch eher also ich würde mich auch zu Full Stack zählen so mittlerweile
Ich meine wie gesagt wir machen Backends sieht man ja im Stream im Endeffekt
Wir machen Backend Sachen wir machen Frontend Sachen wir machen eigentlich alles möglich
Wir haben alle möglichen Sachen schon gemacht im Stream
Aber ein bisschen Frontend schadet keinem was wenn man sich ein bisschen überlegt
Okay wie wird es am Ende denn angezeigt
Was ist Full Stack
Ja im Prinzip Kombination aus Frontend und Backend
Also du kennst dich mit beidem ganz gut aus
Und mit ein bisschen was dazwischen
Vielleicht kennst du dich auch noch ein bisschen mit dem Prinzip System aus wo das ganze drauf läuft oder sowas
Mach einen Monat Hardcore CSS und du bist der Profi drin
Der stimmt jedes mal wenn ich ein bisschen länger wenn ich ein Projekt habe wo ich ein bisschen was Frontend mäßiges machen muss
Hier zum Beispiel Versandtracker oder sowas
Ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht ach das läuft überhaupt nicht
Deswegen ist das kaputt oder doch das läuft
Leute ich habe irgendwas ganz heftig kaputt gemacht
Das Addon macht das? Nein das Addon macht das nicht oder?
Oh megalul das ist das Addon
Hier das ist Fail
Geil
Weiß nicht mehr was ich sagen wollte
Achso man kann das nicht nur für spezielle Seiten an- und ausschalten doch das muss gehen
Die wie Exitlist
Ah jetzt jetzt
Ja wie gesagt ein bisschen Frontend Zeug kriege ich hin
Ich merke das immer selbst wenn ich eine Zeit lang am Stück weil ich Frontend Sachen machen muss
Dann CSS rumbasteln dann weiter kenne ich auch mehr auch bis es JavaScript genau das Problem ist wenn man das nicht konsistent macht oder nicht konstant macht vergisst man saumäßig viel
Gehört PHP zu Frontend oder zu Backend? PHP gehört zu Backend
PHP ist eindeutig Backend wir reden jetzt mal nicht von diesen komischen PHP Seiten wo quasi HTML und PHP alles in einem ist
Aber sonst ist PHP eindeutig Backend ich meine Frontend ist alles das was im Browser läuft ganz einfach eigentlich und PHP kommt nie im Browser an also PHP Backend
Ja und jetzt ich weiß jetzt sagt der nächste JavaScript dann muss man halt bei JavaScript ein bisschen genauer unterscheiden ist es das JavaScript was im Browser läuft oder ist es JavaScript was auf dem Backend läuft
Wobei die so mit den neuen WebAssembly Geschichten verschwimmt das ganze ein bisschen
Wir haben uns ja letztens im Streamer Blazer angeguckt also quasi das.NET von Microsoft für den Browser das das WebAssembly.NET
Also die es ist natürlich immer noch klar was Server ist und was Frontend ist aber es verschwimmt so ein bisschen durch die Geschichte dadurch dass man dann quasi dann auch C Sharp oder C++ oder C quasi im Browser machen kann
So was macht ja keiner der noch bei Verstand ist was da gerade im Chat mit PHP steht
Ich bin nicht der super krasse PHP Owner also ich habe wenig mit PHP gemacht
Das einzige bisschen größere was ich mal mit PHP gemacht habe in den letzten Jahren ist eine Stats und Profil Seite für meinen Battlefield Server und das habe ich halt auch nur in PHP gemacht mit Laravel damals in PHP gemacht weil halt eben jeder Popel Host da PHP dabei hat
Ok gucken wir uns das ganze mal weiter an also Fullstack würde ich mir mittlerweile auch dazu zählen man muss ja nicht alles perfekt können
Backend Frontend kriege ich auch noch gebacken wie gesagt hier würde ich mich nicht als Experte irgendwie sehen
Frontend angeht Developer Desktop oder Enterprise Applications
Enterprise Applications
Ich meine die Sachen die ich auf der Arbeit mache das sind ja eher irgendwelche internen Tools nicht Teil unserer eigentliche Anwendung die dann der Außendienst ändert
Developer Mobile da muss ich sagen ich würde gerne mehr Mobile Zeug machen einfach um mit das mal ein bisschen anzugucken ich habe so gut wie nichts Mobile gemacht bisher
Das einzige was ich bisher Mobile gemacht habe ist ich habe mal versucht ein paar Progressive Web Apps laufen zu lassen und festgestellt dass die Unterstützung bei Apple übelst für ein Arsch ist
Was ist nach deiner Erfahrung der beste Lieferant in Deutschland also Hermes DHL oder UPS
Ja wenn du mich als Käufer fragst bin ich immer froh wenn die Sachen bei DHL verschickt werden es ist regional ein bisschen unterschiedlich aber ich persönlich finde DHL immer am stressfreiesten
Probleme gibt es mit allen ab und zu aber DHL funktioniert gut DHL hat überall Abholstation wunderbar
Was auch ganz cool ist mittlerweile wenn man so eine Amazon Station um die Ecke hat gibt es mittlerweile komplett eigene Amazon Packstation
Aus Sicht von jemanden der Sachen verschickt weiß ich es nicht
Was ist aus dem Paket Tracker geworden da ist er da ist er der Paket Tracker
Bisschen hübscher gemacht mittlerweile
Bisschen hübscher gemacht und wir hatten das gerade gefragt der Boss FTW du hast mittlerweile auch eine History drin und es sieht natürlich schöner aus
Du hast sogar unterschiedliche Statussymbole wie wo das gerade ist hier ist es im Auto wird geliefert hier ist es noch auf dem Weg zu einem und hier ist es angekommen
Ist natürlich bei Weihrauch nicht fertig da kann man doch ewig dran rum basteln haben wir wegen dem Stream auch was zu tun
Ja also wenn ich mal was mobile ausprobieren würde so richtig so richtig mobile jetzt keine PWA Geschichte
Da würde ich wahrscheinlich wirklich auch mal zum Anlass nehmen mir Flutter anzugucken
Das würde ich mir mal angucken weil es geht ja wenn ich irgendwas mobile mäßig mache wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht darum gehen dass ich eine App basteln will die ich wirklich leasen möchte in App Store
Dann einfach zum ausprobieren und dann würde ich mal wirklich Flutter ausprobieren das ist ja schwer im Kommen
Es ist halt noch recht neu ein paar Sachen wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht dafür geben was ich ganz cool finde und warum ich mir auch schon überlegt habe man müsste sich eigentlich mal Flutter angucken
Weil das wohl auch immer mehr im Kommen ist dass jetzt Desktop als Plattform unterstützt wird
Und vielleicht haben wir es ja mit Flutter oder vielleicht schaffen sie es ja mit Flutter mal wirklich ein ordentliches GUI Framework zu kreieren
Dass man wirklich auf allen verbreiteten Desktops und Mobile Geräten einsetzen kann
Das wäre natürlich extrem pock wenn das mal funktionieren würde
Weil Flutter hat den richtigen GUI Ansatz ich finde Xamarin suckt aus dem einfachen Grund weil die halt also erstens weil sie extrem übertreiben was ihre XAML Geschichte angeht
Aber es steht ja im Endeffekt das Ding aus 90% XML und 10% Logik aber was mir bei Xamarin auch nicht gefällt ist dass sie den gemeinsamen kleinen GUI Nenner von allen Betriebssystem nehmen
Also sprich alle Betriebssysteme die du unterstützen nehmen sie die Native Controls
Linux ich glaube es gibt sogar mittlerweile eine Alpha oder Beta Variante für Linux die GTK verwendet
Das Problem was du damit hast ist wenn du deine Controls da habe ich mir schon oft darüber ausgelassen
Wenn du deine Controls nicht selber malst als GUI Framework bist du immer davon abhängig dass du quasi den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner aller Plattformen die du supportest nimmst
Und wenn ein Button dann eben bei der einen Plattform kein Bild kann dann kann halt dein Button nirgendwo ein Bild
Deswegen gefällt mir das nicht
Ich finde alle ordentlichen GUI Frameworks malen ihre GUI Elemente selber
Und im besten Fall natürlich mit irgendeiner Low Level Technik sprich unter Windows werden die Dinge da mit DirectX gemalt oder mit Direct2D
Und unter allen anderen Plattformen werden sie entweder mit OpenGL oder irgendwas anderem gemalt
Das ist eigentlich der beste Ansatz
Qt macht das auch so
Qt
Da wollten wir übrigens auch mal eine Test App basteln
Nein mein nächstes Team fällt mir gerade so ein
So also muss immer stehen geblieben wobei kein Schimmer Student nein Database Administrator
Datenbank ist so echt ist echt so ein Thema wo ich sagen muss da könnte ich auch noch sehr viel sehr viel lernen
Ich meine ich kriege so basic Sachen hin ja ich kriege ich kriege mal einen Join hin ich kann mal irgendwie bisschen SQL zusammen basteln
Ich kann ein paar Subselects machen oder sowas
Aber wirklich großartig Plan von Datenbanken habe ich
Da gehört ja auch einiges an Theorie dahinter wie man das am besten aufbaut
Weil man so Popel Anwendungen die wir hier im Stream machen ist es nicht weiter wild
Aber bei ordentlichen Anwendungen kommt es natürlich darauf an dass die Datenbank auch dementsprechend durchdacht ist
So Designer also was Design angeht
Bin ich also was Grafik und so angeht bin ich nicht gut
Ich finde ich kann ganz gut einschätzen was farblich zusammen passt halbwegs aber
Irgendwelche Sachen zeichnen oder oder oder
Seinen
Ich meine ihr müsst euch guckt mal wenn ihr meine Designer Skills sehen wollt müsst ihr euch nur die Thumbnails von meinem YouTube Channel angucken
Da wisst ihr schon Bescheid
Was ich zum Thema Design sage
Für YouTube Verhältnisse sind die gar nicht übelbar die Thumbnails
Aber
Die hohe Kunst ist es jetzt nicht
Die hohe Kunst ist es jetzt echt nicht
Vor allem das da
Also was haben sie sonst noch hier
Das ist das womit ich gerade mein Geld verdiene
Embedded Applications bis auf ein bisschen ESP32 Arduino
Keine Ahnung mir fällt immer wieder auf wenn ich mir solche Listen ausguck dass ich mich relativ breit eigentlich auskenne
Aber halt wenig wirklich richtig gut
Alter Morpheus jetzt diss mal meine meine Thumbnails nicht sonst gibts Disabo
Data Scientist oder Machine Learning Specialist
Qualitätssicherung
Ja das also die Verteilung kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen
Und das darf man so auch gar nicht mehr sagen
Nach Gender geordnet
Die Statistik verstehe ich nicht
Wo sehe ich jetzt was was ist
Kann man das hier irgendwie anklicken
Kann man hier irgendwie umschalten zwischen Frauen Männer
Versteht das jemand
Gewichtet und nicht sortiert
Ja und was was bedeutet gewichtet in dem Fall
Die Statistik verstehe ich nicht
Gewichtet also hat eine Frau mehr Prozentpunkte als ein Mann
Ach so meinst du ist das so verteilt
Also sprich quasi dass das keine Ahnung
Wenn 100 Männer und eine Frau abgestimmt haben und die hätten dann gesagt
Hätten sich hier drauf verteilt dass dann quasi das wo die eine Frau abgestimmt hat
Quasi weiter also mehr Punkte quasi kriegt
Was auch immer die Statistik jetzt sagen soll
Keine Ahnung
Das ist jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht dass es im Frontend
Im Frontend und im Design Bereich mehr Mädels gibt
Sein ja doch tatsächlich im Design Bereich gibt es mehr Mädels
Ansonsten ist die Statistik eigentlich ziemlich irrelevant oder
Find ich nicht schön gemacht
Contributing to Open Source Software
Interessant
Also ich finde es interessant dass so viele immer noch
Gar nichts damit am Hut haben
So dass ich wahnsinnig viel kontributen würde
Also ich befinde mich auch hier drin
Ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch jetzt befinden mich hier drin
Nicht oft aber ab und zu
Coding ist ein Hobby
Ja auf jeden Fall sonst würde ich ja hier keinen Streben machen
Ich programmiere auch außerhalb von der Arbeit
Wobei ich ja wie gesagt der Arbeit nicht mal hauptsächlich programmieren
Deswegen finde ich das hier gerade gut dass wir das im Stream machen können
Redi Germany das ist eigentlich total einfach
Wenn du Software benutzt die Open Source ist die ein GitHub Projekt hat
Und die irgendwas auf den Keks geht oder du auch nur Verbesserungsvorschläge hast
Oder vielleicht sogar auch nur die API Doku bisschen schöner schreiben willst
Kannst du mitmachen die meisten freuen sich drüber
Und oftmals ist es so dass gerade die einfachen Dinge auch erwähnt werden auf der Seite
Weil man damit hofft man kriegt die Leute dazu einzusteigen
Also beispielsweise Linux Kernel macht das so
Die sagen oder die ermutigen quasi Leute dazu Dokumentationsfixes einzureichen und sowas
Jetzt eben habe ich es gerade übertrieben mit kopieren oder
Weil die halt hoffen dass die Leute damit den Einstieg finden
So wirklich Code Contributen für die Linux Kernel an sich das könnten eh nur die wenigsten
Aber ich meine alles ist besser als nichts
Ja hier auch auf jeden Fall ja
Macht auch keinen großen Unterschied
Macht auch weltweit keinen großen Unterschied
Hier Science Learning Jahre seit man Programmieren gelernt hat
Boah alter 50 Jahre näh
Wie lang ist denn das her 2000 wann kam denn
Wann kam denn.NET kam 2.NET Framework 2 raus
Hier 2002 so ein bisschen davor habe ich angefangen schon rumzubasteln
Also sagen wir 2001
Also 15 15 Jahre 15 bis 19 Jahre
Da würde ich mich wieder finden
Da sind noch Lochkarten Programmierer dabei also hier unten auf jeden Fall
50 Jahre
Die haben noch Kabel zwischen unterschiedlichen Registern geschleppt
Und damals hat man ja Kabel nicht gelötet
Damals hat man Kabel ja gedreht um die Kontakte
Wenn du wieder nach der Schule wärst würdest du wieder Programmierer werden oder was anderes
Ich würde schon wieder machen ich habe gesagt ich habe ich habe ich habe die Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt
Ich habe System Integration gelernt damals
Und ich habe auch in dem Bereich eine Weile geschafft
Aber mittlerweile bin ich halt im DevOps Bereich gelandet
Aber ich programmiere halt auch schon seit 15 bis 19 Jahren
So hier ist Coding Professionelle
Englisch Pro wieder angesagt
Ja das ist schwierig so richtig
Also ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Programmierer
Also ich meine ich programmiere auf der Arbeit auch was
Aber hauptsächlich lese ich den Code von anderen Leuten
Was ja nicht wirklich Programmieren ist
Allerdings jetzt seit ich Twitch Partner bin ist natürlich noch viel besser
Weil wenn ich jetzt auf Twitch programmiere ist das ja auch professionell programmieren
Weil professionell heißt ja eigentlich nur dass man Geld für kriegt
Man muss ja auch nicht gut sein
Das wird ja oft mal verwechselt ja
Nur weil irgendjemand sagt er ist er ist er ist professionell heißt es nicht dass er gut ist
Das heißt nur dann für den Geld mit
Ich würde mal sagen
Also wenn man mal sagen
Wenn man mal damit rechnet so
Den aktuellen Job wo ich jetzt bin
Da bin ich seit 2000
Also dann würde ich sagen hier
DevOps hört sich schon nice an
DevOps ist total auch eines der Buzzwords schlechthin
Wobei es schon wieder ab
Abflacht
Heute musst du Cloud Architekt sein
Um hip zu sein
Du musst auch wissen wie du deinen Kubernetes richtig schön scalest
Und wie du FAS verwendest
Kein Mensch weiß was FAS heißt eigentlich
Function as a Service
Wer auch immer sich das ausgedacht hat
FAS
Das hört sich übelst kaputt an
Serverless Microservice natürlich
Natürlich
Serverless Microservice Architekt
Huge Big Brain
Das kannst du nicht einfach mit normalem
Mit normalem Hirn machen
Also da brauchst du schon ein extra großes Hirn
Ok weiter mal gucken
Ähm
Was ich hier aber eigentlich ganz interessant finde ist
Dass es anscheinend wenige Leute gibt
Die den Kram lange lange durchhalten
Gut ich mein so richtig
Ich mein guck mal
2000 rum gab es auch schon viele Programmierer
Ich glaube auf Dauer macht das kaum einer
Lange
Guck mal es haben
Es haben weniger es haben 20%
Das nur in den letzten 5 Jahren gelernt
Und Arbeiten tun 41%
Das heißt es haben viele Leute vorher gelernt
Und dann erst später zum Beruf gemacht
Aber ich kann es verstehen
Wenn man wirklich den ganzen Tag
Programmieren muss
Kann es schon sein dass man nach einer Weile
Kein Bock mehr drauf hat
Vor allem wahrscheinlich in der Gaming Industrie
Ähm Entwickler mit
Oh Visual Basic
Nein das ist nicht mal Visual Basic
Das ist VBA
Das ist Visual Basic
For Applications oder wie der Kram heißt
Monka Shake
Visual Basic
F sharp
Ok dachte nicht dass da so viele
Lange dabei sind
Ok
Kotlin haben die
Wenigsten Erfahrungen aber gut das gibt es auch nicht so
Lang PAP auch die wenigsten
PAP hat ganz lange Leute schon
Paisen auch gut das Paisen
Ist ja auch erst die letzten 10 Jahre so richtig
In den letzten 5 Jahren so richtig hip geworden
Obwohl es es auch schon
Eine ewig lange gibt
Schon 20 Jahre oder so
Aber länger
Ok und jetzt was
Was sie sind was die Leute
Was die Leute gelernt haben
Vice President
Ja ok das
Ach so mit dem unterschiedlichen
Mit den unterschiedlichen Erfahrungen
Ja gut als Senior Executive Vice President
Da programmierst du ja nicht mehr selbst
Du programmierst Erfahrung und dann machst du
Was anderes
Ah da bin ich
Da passe ich doch eigentlich ganz gut rein
Mit allem was bisher
Da deckt sich ziemlich gut
Mit
Mit meinen Erfahrungen auch so
Game oder Graphics
Das sind so die durchschnittlichen Jahre
Die man Erfahrung hat
Ja gut
Den Bereich gibt es ja noch gar nicht so
Lang
Hast du ein Microsoft
DevOps Zertifikat
Muss ich gar nicht heißen
Microsoft DevOps Zertifikat gibt
Es geht um die
Erste Teile Code
Die erste Zeile Code
Boah
Keine Ahnung
Wann kommen die Modes
Wenn ich welche gemacht hab
Das erste was es gibt
Ist auf jeden Fall Wupp S
Wupp S
Was ist das
Das erste
das ist okay ich habe keine ahnung mehr
jünger als 30 auf jeden fall jünger als 20
die erste zeile code
erste zeile code wird glaube ich in der schule irgendwas sein
keine ahnung keine ahnung echt keine keinen plassen shimmer
wahrscheinlich so in dem dreh hier oder so aber echt keine ahnung
finde es interessant dass es leute gibt die unter 10 schon angefangen haben
heißt nicht dass sie unbedingt dabei geblieben sind
wie ich sehe hast du dir da wieder angeschaut ja aber auch nur weil das jemand empfohlen hat
im stream vorhin wie viel geld bleibt man vom sub eigentlich über ich glaube 50 50 ich hab
es mir jetzt nicht durchgelesen aber war ja im vorfeld immer wieder ging ja immer wieder die
auch quasi die gerüchte um dass man so als als nur nach 15 wird spartner 50 50 kriegt ich
habe es nicht durchgelesen ich habe es mir nicht durchgelesen ich glaube 50 50 also die 11 also
das heißt ich müsste jetzt subs habe ich jetzt muss mal gucken subschreiber ist jetzt 131 131
mal 2,5 easy money 327 euro da kann man auch schon was mit anfangen und ich wollte gar nicht
ihr habt mich ja dazu gedrängt partner zu werden ich habe ja schon zwei jahre gestreamt ohne partner
zu sein mehr steuern muss ich gar nicht so viele bezahlen weil ich habe ich was ich verdiene so
wenig mit mit youtube und zeug in letzter zeit aber ich habe noch viele sachen die abgeschrieben
werden gerade weil ich die mal gekauft habe und auch neue sachen die ich kaufe halt auch für die
letztendlich diese tätigkeit hier oder auch für youtube oder generell für sachen die halt
irgendwas mit der firma zu tun haben kann ich auch alle abrechnen also eigentlich ganz gut
das die letzten jahre habe ich immer steuer wieder gekriegt education how many developers are students
nope weder jetzt noch früher
ich kenne mich mit dem amis schulsystem nicht aus ich habe keine ahnung wo ich da drin stecke also
ich habe keinen doktor ich habe kein professionell degree ich weiß gar nicht was das ist habe kein
masters degree ich habe kein bachelor degree ich habe kein was auch immer ein associate degree ist
ich habe kein without degree primary school ist grundschule oder secondary school ist was
realschule gymnasium da bin ich nicht drinne ich habe ganz normal schule gemacht und dann
habe ich eine ausbildung gemacht weiß nicht wo das hier dazu zählt noch mal easy doktor titel
lehnen war ja passt irgendwie nicht so meine weiterbildung macht ich habe ein paar sachen also ich
habe ein paar schulungen mal mitgemacht aber die meisten schulungen gehen mir ehrlich gesagt
richtig auf den keks die einzige schulung die wirklich ganz gut war die ich gemacht habe
war ipv6 das hat auch jemand gemacht der sich auskennt fand ich ganz interessant die anderen
schulungen sind alle zum kurs dann echt langweilig gewesen am schlimmsten fand ich immer schulungen
wo es nicht um irgendwelche technik geht sondern um irgendwelche wie verbessere ich meine soft
skills oder sowas da gehe ich nicht mehr hin also solche schulungen gehe ich nicht mehr
das kommt aber auch glaube ich ab einem gewissen alter ab einem gewissen alter ist man nicht
mal belehrbar so richtig also wie gesagt ich bin jetzt seit ein paar tagen 35 und ich lasse
mir auch nichts mehr erzählen also ich will mir auch irgendwie nichts mehr erzählen lassen
es ist vielleicht vielleicht das bescheuert ja und ich weiß selbst dass ich in manchen
bereichen nicht der sozial sag mal mal nicht in manchen bereichen selbst dass ich das sozial
nicht der beste bin wie gesagt ich mag leute also ich mag andere menschen in der regel
halt nicht habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt es sei denn ich mag sie aber die folgen ist
ich mag sie eigentlich erstmal nicht außerdem natürlich mal ein chat wobei es stimmt so
nicht also in der regel in der regel bin ich eigentlich neutral bei neuen leuten aber
sobald die mir auf den sack gehen und das geht halt relativ schnell mag ich sie nicht
mehr naja so ist richtig habe ich euch ein paar frage ich glaube ich habe ein paar fragen
über sehen kann das sein so viel zeug leise sabbetsch eigentlich fünf minuten vom stream
extra mal eingerichtet hat der m core gestern mal kurz die bilder
hast du code zum liegungskern schon mal kontributed nein ist gaming ein heil fischbecken habe
ich mal gehört ich kann ich kann es ja aus erster hand nicht sagen aber alles was ich
höre ist es für den arsch ich kann jemand da bei crytag arbeiten der sagt aus ist für
den arsch mein crytag ist in frankfurt bei uns um die ecke
und kommen emotes hatten wir schon als fertig ist sobald mir was eingefallen ist auch schon
das stimmt so mal weiter gucken an der great major was an der great major ach das überspringen
war aber ich habe ich kenne mich mit dem ami bildungssystem nicht aus was das ist
ach das ist wenn du an der universität studiert hast in was in was du studiert hast
einfach monka smoke ich kann monka smoke nicht als emot einrichten weil ich als prefix muss
die wupp verwenden ich kann höchstens wupps maul nehmen ob es man auch machen weiß gar
nicht ich weiß gar nicht wie wie das klein aussieht das bild muss mal gucken wie das
in die mautgröße überhaupt ausschaut ob man den smoke überhaupt erkennt in die mautgröße
was crytag jetzt eigentlich macht ist eine gute frage die machen so ein komisches battle
royale western western battle royale game die basteln an ihrer cry engine rum was macht
der gute frage keine ahnung showdown ja
new language framework without formal kurs klar das hatte jeder also es gibt keinen guten
programmierer oder generell ich erweitere es mal auf es gibt keinen keiner der im technischen
bereich gut ist der nicht mal allein eine neue sprache neues framework oder neue sachen gelernt
hat leute die immer die leute die da sitzen und so lang sagen ich kann es nicht bis ich
eine schuldung bekommen hab sie in der regel die übelsten oberkacknubs weil die sich auch
absolut nicht dafür interessieren cheat ich muss nicht wupp nehmen aber ich habe wupp
jetzt mal als prefix genommen weil es irgendwie ganz gut zum channel passt max war besetzt
max und m4x war besetzt da habe ich jetzt einfach mal wupp genommen weil wupp ist schön mit
wupp kann man schön kombinieren wupp ein wupps kann man sich auch gut merken
ein online kurs hat auch schon jeder mal gemacht und jubilete open source software habe ich
auch schon gemacht on the job training in software nein auf der arbeit hat sich noch
keine aber hatte ich noch keine keine veranstaltung was programmieren oder development angeht
bei einem hackathon habe ich auch noch nicht mitgemacht online coding competition ja mache
ich jeden tag die gucken immer 100 leute zu wenn ich den miss programmieren das kann
man schon alles online coding competition durchgehen lassen oder
ja das habe ich tatsächlich schon mal gemacht wo ich noch sehr jung war habe ich mal einen
kurs gemacht für basic an der volkshochschule da war ich richtig da war ich noch ganz ganz
klein nicht da war ich so da bin ich so keine ahnung wer war ich denn da 14 oder so da habe
ich in volkshochschule kurs in visual basic gemacht wo wir wieder beim thema erste zeile
code sind da habe ich mich dran gedacht jetzt ich weiß nicht was mich da geritten hat ich
glaube mein vater hat damals gesagt er will sie das nicht mal ausprobieren und aber warum
nicht und wisst ihr wie der kurs ist ja komplett fail gelaufen wir hatten da eine lehrerin
das habe ich erst im nachhinein so realisiert wir hatten da eine lehrerin die konnte nur
aus ihrem buch abschreiben und vor allem visual basic die konnten wir aus ihrem buch abschreiben
und wisst ihr was wir dann gemacht haben wir haben uns half life mitgebracht also muss
das also muss das irgendwie 97 98 rum gewesen sein das der war ich 14 und wir haben uns
half life mitgebracht und haben half life auf den volkshochschule pc installiert und
haben dann half life tdm gespielt oder war ganz tdm war nur dm so muss man es machen
und die hat es auch nicht gejuckt weil der kurs wurde ja von den eltern bezahlt in einem
fulltime developer training war ich auch noch nicht ja weil absichtlich fehler eingebaut
oder weil er keinen plan hatte completed in industry certification programm naja die sysco
nub zertifizierung zählt nicht das kriegt jeder hin also diese sysco cc na geschichte
kriegt jeder hin da musste nicht musste nicht sondern ich soll ich pro sein außerdem ist
es kein developer programm ok fast jeder kriegt das hin hast jeder das ist wirklich nicht
schwer wenn man ein bisschen hang zu technik und netzwerk hat es ist easy ich weiß davon
eigentlich nichts mehr weil es nur noch dass man en eingeben muss auf sysco gerät dass
man was machen kann alles mehr habe ich mir nicht gemerkt von und das na doch das sysco
komische bezeichnung hat für trunk ports für bonding ports das habe ich mir noch gemerkt
dass
sysco komische konsolenkabel verwendet was ich für ein mikrofon habe aktuell habe
ich das mikrofon was am mx 300 dran ist normalerweise habe ich schon seit jahren ein blue yeti aber
hier fürs livestream verwende ich das mikrofon was am headset was am mx 300 dran ist alternativ
könnte ich könnte ich noch ein bisschen älteres mod mitnehmen für die anderen kopfhörer mega
nice quality für das das mx 300 hat ein richtig gutes mikro für den headset es ist aber halt
auch viel zu teuer das kostet 250 euro für den headset halt übelst teuer und da muss
halt auch schon mal ein gescheites mikrofon drin sein ansonsten kannst du dir den dt 770
oder sowas holen für den profi die hälfte oder für weniger als die hälfte und ein
gutes mikrofon dazu kaufen hallo flow 96 ja das ist mein video zum thema gaming headsets
das kenne ich noch und es widerspricht sich ja auch überhaupt nicht lohnt sich ja auch
nicht 250 euro auszugeben aber viel einfacher haben
jetzt haben wir das ist die aufteilung von programmierern oder generell von leuten im
technischen bereich nach herkunft ok weiß oder europäische abstammung 70 prozent das
hätte ich jetzt auch nicht mit anders anders gerechnet ihr einfach mal von aus dass in
vielen ländern wo halt die überwiegende teil der der überwiegende teil der leute
eben nicht weiß ist dass es da nicht so viele programmiert jobs gibt oder dass die beim
stack auf war flow serve nicht mitmachen weil in asien gibt es definitiv auch viele programmierer
oh gender jetzt wird es komplett auch jetzt jetzt darf ich nichts falsches sagen
wir haben 91 prozenten männer mitgemacht acht prozent frau mitgemacht und 1,2 non binary
was in allen bereichen ziemlich ähnlich ist
aber rolls in jenna deffa specialist moment was haben wir auf developers relativ participation
heißt das dass es in meinem bereich besonders viele medien gibt oder besonders wenige was
heißt das jetzt bedeutet dass das in meinem bereich besonders vieler besonders wenig gibt
bei mir sind viele männer das stimmt das kann ich unterstreichen ich habe es ja letztens
im stream gesagt dass wir nur zwei medels haben das stimmt nicht wir haben wir haben
schon mehr medels aber bei uns im bereich gibt es gibt es eigentlich nur zwei medels
und wo wir viele haben ist ios app entwicklung und und app design da haben wir viele mehr
als 25 mal so viel als frauen ja wie gesagt bei uns im bereich gibt es auch im prinzip
da gibt es gibt wirklich uns gibt es sehr wenige medels experience warum kriegen frauen
die medels
Ja okay, das wundert mich jetzt nicht, dass es mehr Mädels in dem Beruf gibt, das hat ja auch erst die letzten zehn Jahre wirklich deutlich zugenommen.
Davor hat es ja quasi gar keine Mädels und mittlerweile hast du doch vereinzelt auch mal Mädels.
Ja also im Durchschnitt, sagen wir mal so, im Durchschnitt 15 bis 20 mal so viele Männer auf Frauen.
Bei uns in der Technik, da bei uns in der Technikecke, wo ich arbeite, also nehmen wir mal alles zusammen, was damit Technik zu tun hat.
Das spiegelt sich ungefähr wieder, ja. Also würde ich sagen, 20 bis 15 mal mehr Männer als Frauen, das kommt ungefähr hin.
Dafür ist es halt in anderen Bereichen genau umgedreht. Wenn du in der Personalabteilung guckst, weiß ich gar nicht, ob da überhaupt ein Mann arbeitet bei uns.
Bei Appdesign und IOS sind auch sehr viele Mädels.
Wo haben wir denn noch viele Mädels?
Marketing und Bullshitbingo hat auch viele Mädels bei uns.
Halt auch weniger Typen.
Kantine und Kantine ist eigentlich, würde ich sagen, ziemlich ausgeglichen.
Ja Flow 96, also ohne Mist so.
Wenn man den Job will, wo man viele Mädels um sich hat, musste in die Personalabteilung oder IOS-Entwickler werden.
Zumindest kann ich das bei uns so beobachten.
Was ist denn Bullshitbingo? Sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Da haben wir noch von der letzten E3. EA Bullshitbingo.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Orientierung, sexuelle Orientierung, Ausrichtung.
Die meisten sind, wer hätte das gedacht, einfach nur ganz normal.
5,5 sind bi und schwul und lesbisch sind 2,7.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sich das wahrscheinlich ungefähr decken wird mit den normalen Bevölkerungszahlen auch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es im Bereich im Technikbereich jetzt so viel mehr ist.
Ich glaube, das ist überall recht ähnlich, oder?
93% ist normal. Normal ist das, was die Mehrheit ist.
Das heißt nicht, dass normal besser, schlechter oder sonst was ist.
Normal ist einfach nur, was die Mehrheit ist.
Erstmal gleich triggert hier im Chat.
Ich weiß, dass mein Chat fake triggert ist.
Aber heutzutage muss ich echt übelst krass aufpassen bei sowas.
Wo sind die Weeps in der Statistik? Stimmt.
Das geht ja gar nicht. Wo sind sie?
Die müssen da auch rein.
Da bräuchte es ja zumindest noch was für...
Ja, das geht ja so nicht.
Behindertenstatus.
Aber eine Stimmungs- und Emotionsstörung.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Also, es wurde nie diagnostiziert.
Dass ich sie nicht mehr alle habe, ist mir auch klar.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das krankhaft gestört ist.
Wie gesagt, festgestellt wurde nichts.
Autismus habe ich auch nicht.
Konzentrationsstörung habe ich aber auch nicht.
Nicht diagnostiziert.
Ich habe da nichts.
Prime-Sub.
Und zwar haben wir da den Shingekuro.
Hoffe, das war jetzt nicht komplett pale.
Dankeschön Twitch Prime.
Ah, Scheiß.
Ich glaube, wir haben ein neues Emote freigeschaltet.
Also, wo ich keine Emotes habe.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe jetzt einen neuen Emote-Slot bekommen gerade.
Jetzt habe ich schon 11 Emotes.
Also 0 von 11 Emotes.
Vorher hatte ich nur 0 von 10 Emotes.
Aber was geht eigentlich mit der Musik da im Hintergrund ab?
Woch, hat sich das jetzt reloadet irgendwie?
Age.
Oh, ich bin schon zu alt.
Guck mal.
Vor 5 Tagen war ich noch hier.
Habe ich noch hier dazu gehört.
Jetzt gehöre ich dazu.
Neben vorbei.
Dankeschön Tobi.
Durchschnittliches Alter, Deutschland, 30.
Da bin ich ja schon voll drüber.
Guck mal, die Deutschen sind Programmier-Noobs.
Die Australier, die kennen sie aus.
Sie fühlten sich 35 Jahre an, also im Vergleich zu 34.
Ja, natürlich ist es überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Indien, 25.
Indien, 7,1.
Na gut, das ist der Microsoft-Support.
Mein Name ist Peter.
Warum hört sich Peter indisch an?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist doch der Typ hier, wartet mal.
Kennt ihr das?
Was ist das denn?
Das da?
Das muss man sich mal angucken.
Das war lustig.
Mein Name ist Peter.
Wo ist die Musik?
Was hat der für ein Mikrofon?
Was ist das für ein Mikrofon?
Hat der das unter dem Schreibtisch hängen und sich drauf gesetzt?
Max erwartet Studio-Qualität-Mikros von Scammers.
Das ist nicht das Scammer.
Das ist ein Scammer.
Das nicht das Scammer.
Das ist der Scammer, der den Scammer scammt.
Mit ordentlichem Aufnahme-Equipment.
Egal.
Wir gucken uns das euch an.
20 Minuten.
müssen wir Ihren Computer deaktivieren und weitere Schäden an unserem Netzwerk verhindert werden.
Außerdem werden wir eine Kopie dieses Berichts an die Netzsicherheit schicken, um weitere Schritte einzuleiten.
Machen Sie so bitte, drücken Sie diese Windows-Taste!
Warum hören die sich auch immer alle so gleich an?
Es geht jetzt überhaupt nicht um Inder-Klischee oder so, aber die hören sich alle so an, die ganzen Scammer hören sich so an!
So, und gleichzeitig spuckst aber R, R wie Rudolf!
R wie Rudolf?
Ist die Lautstärke okay vom Scammer?
Spuckst aber R, R wie Rudolf!
Hinter den Explorer erst mal aufmachen!
Ja, bitte!
Jawoll, habe ich! Jetzt bin ich hier auf fastsupport.com, Verbindung für Support aufbauen!
Ja, genau, schreiben Sie zuerst Ihren Namen und dann gebe ich Ihnen einen Support-Schlüssel!
Ja, einen kleinen Moment!
Ich meine...
Die Support-Schlüssel lautet Zahnlnummer 8-4-0!
Ja?
639...
Ich meine, das ist übelst kompliziert!
Wenn die versucht hätten, meine Oma zu scammen oder sowas, hätte das Scam schon mal nicht funktioniert, weil die noch nicht mal in der Lage gewesen wäre, sowas zu befolgen überhaupt!
Der Scam ist viel zu kompliziert!
Missbrauch melden!
Wahrscheinlich, weil fastsupport.com von so vielen seriösen Leuten verwendet wird!
639...
696...
Jetzt klicken Sie auf weiter!
Ja, habe ich!
Ja bitte, jetzt bekommen Sie ein Opsi und unten aus!
Sollte den Scheiß auch noch downloaden! Schon ewig her, dass ich das geguckt habe!
Es wird immer seriöser, es wird immer seriöser jetzt!
Möchten Sie go to assist-opener-exe downloaden? Ja, unbedingt!
Ausführen zu klicken!
Jawoll, ausführen, um go to assist-opener zu starten!
Ja, klicken Sie auf ausführen bitte!
Hab ich!
Initialisierung!
Na, diese Installierung, Sie sollen auf ja klicken!
Immer auf ja klicken!
Ok, go to assist wird ge...
Das ist bis jetzt noch eine ganz normale go to assist...
Wahrscheinlich...
Ganz ehrlich, ich kenne dieses Programm nicht...
Kann sein, dass es vollkommen legit ist!
Ich bricht ja auch nichts dagegen, die wollen ja einfach Remote Zugang haben!
Wahrscheinlich wäre es einfacher mit irgendeinem fertigen...
Wie heißt das?
Teamviewer oder sowas? Aber keine Ahnung!
Bis jetzt ist ja noch ok! Bis jetzt ist ja noch halbwegs normal!
Ja bitte, Sie sollen wieder und wieder auf ja klicken!
Immer ja klicken!
Ja...
So, jetzt ist self-inan weiter, ja warten Sie bitte!
Ja wunderbar!
Jetzt, jetzt kommt es gleich!
Moment!
Best... also...
Die, die gibt es, die gibt ihn jetzt gleich an anderen Support-Mitarbeiter weiter!
Und da müsst ihr mal drauf hören, wie der sich meldet!
Ja bitte! Sie haben wirklich sehr gut gemacht!
Jetzt ist self-inan weiter, ja!
Ja bitte, lasst uns Ihren Maus frei bitte, ok?
Ok!
So, wir haben einen Fehler bekommen, richtig?
Zugriff hat gelähmt, richtig?
Was?
Richtig, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, wie die Meldung hieß...
Ich hatte mir die Telefonnummer jetzt aufgeschrieben...
Und dann versucht selber irgendwie da ein bisschen was zu machen...
Moment, ja!
Ja bitte, so warten Sie bitte!
So Herr Wasmacher ist hier für Sie am besten...
Ich leite dieser Anruf...
Einmal direkt zu meinem Hochqualifizierter-Techniker, ok?
Der Hochqualifizierter-Techniker!
Ja bitte!
Und der Student dabei, ok?
Ja, danke sehr!
Jetzt pass mal auf, wie der sich meldet!
Vielen Dank für die Wegfalle, Satran Kirchner!
Sind Sie noch da? Hallo?
Ich bin noch da, ja!
Das ist so geil, ey!
Das erwischt mich jedes Mal, ey!
Mein Name ist Peter!
Ist klar!
Natürlich!
Wie soll der sonst heißen?
Nein, natürlich Peter!
Ey komm, wir gucken das jetzt noch fertig!
Geht ja nur noch 17 Minuten, ne?
15 Minuten!
Wunderbar, Peter!
Sie haben dieses Problem bekommen, zum SS mal, richtig?
Richtig, das war gestern oder vorgestern?
Vorgestern war es tatsächlich, abends irgendwann!
Aha, ok, ok!
Ist klar, ne?
Ich kann jetzt hier auf dem Computer wieder arbeiten und dieses Problem auch wieder einigen, ne?
Jawoll!
Was macht Peter da?
Ja!
Ja, ok!
So, warten Sie!
Was?
Ja, ja, warten Sie!
So, wir machen die Problem schnell und dann werden sie auch wieder lösen, ja?
Ja!
Ich warte, ich warte, bis sie fertig sind!
Ja, ja, warten Sie!
Das ist so geil!
Das ist so geil
Da hat keine ahnung was machen war der findet noch nicht mal was er sucht das ist da ist nicht nur der scammer das eine unfähiger scammer
So wir checken erstmal die Hintergrundvideos von Ihrem Computer, wie viele Hintergrundvideos gibt es in Ihrem Computer?
Das zeig mal
Ja
Wissen Sie warum bekommen Sie diese Warnung in Ihrem Computer?
Ne weiß ich leider nicht, also ich war auch ganz überrascht
Und weiter?
Okay jetzt sagt der nächste Mal
Sie können mal hier schauen Issue 1 oder 2 mehr hast du 100 Fehler und Warnungen gibt es in Ihrem Computer in die Hintergrund
Können Sie einmal das alles schauen
Ja sehe ich
Da brauchst du schon BigBrain um so eine Idee zu kommen
So viele Hackversuche
Irgend ein komisches.NET Programm ist abgekackt
Der hat irgendwie Strom eingeschaltet
Fail
Der Timo Twitch Prime Dankeschön
Pog
Subscriber
Nice
Es gibt Leute
Es gibt tausende solche Inder Scam Videos
Okay ja ich sehe es
Ja logisch
Ja sehe ich
Wir müssen diese Anleitarten von Ihrem Computer ganz ganz blockieren und auch weg machen damit Sie können den Computer von den Phatastik aktivieren
Ist doch ganz klar oder
Ah jetzt
Erstmal TCP
Und Netzdat
Genau Netzdat
So schlecht
Sie können hier sehen
Hier ist Ihr lokaler Adress
Ja
Das ist die Adresse von meinem Computer
Das ist so unglaubliche Fail Erklärung
Die ist nicht nur
Die ist nicht nur dumm
Die ist auf so vielen Ebenen
So viele Fail
Okay also die Leute haben jetzt alle Zugriff auf meinen Rechner
Natürlich
Was sonst natürlich
So klar
Komm wir gucken mal wie viele Leute Zugriff auf meinen Rechner aktuell haben
Netzdat mit Parameter einfach nur Netzdat
Oh fuck
Fuck
Jetzt bin ich im Arsch
Warum genau hat sich mein Rechner zu meinem Shield TV verbunden?
Warum?
Wahrscheinlich ist es der Chrome
Wahrscheinlich ist es der Chrome der Chromecast scannt oder so
Die krassen Hacksore
Hier guckt euch das mal an
Kann man nicht sagen im Minus N dass er keinen Nameblock hat?
Guck mal hier
So viele Hacker
Fuck
Jetzt vorbei
Wer shade ein Hacker
Was sie können using
Hergestellt
Moment
Da haben wir jetzt gar nicht danach geguckt
Wir haben gar nicht geguckt ob es hergestellt war
Gut bei mir steht wahrscheinlich established da aber
Alles voller Hacker
Vor allem hacken mich ja auch 20 Mal selber hier oben
Darf man nicht vergessen
Also ich hack mich erst ein paar Mal selber
und dann werde ich von meiner vm gehackt
und dann hackt mich amazon
klipp
so diese personen können
jeder seite in ihrem computer rein kommen
und irgendwas falsches machen und so weiter und so weiter
aha ok
wir müssen diese alle
wir müssen diese alle ip adressen von ihrem computer
diese impektierung von ihrem
computer ganz ganz weg machen
mhm ok
ganz ganz weg
aber tatsächlich
das ist ihre ip adress und
jeder rechner hat eine eigene ip adress
ja ok verstehe
ok
jetzt ist gerade hier auch eine scanning
in ihrem computer durchschulen lassen aber
geben sie mir noch eine Minute Zeit
ja gerne
so habe ich jetzt
selber auch eine andere
probleme bekommen
ok
ich werde hier eine scanning
in ihrem computer durchschulen lassen
ok
was
koop face
was ist koop face
ist das irgendein malware
ja aber leute
jetzt lernt ihr mal wenigstens was
also wenn ihr keine ahnung von
hacktechnik habt
schaut euch das video mit peta an
wissen sie was ist koop face
koop face
das weiß ich nicht erklären sie mir mal
was ist das ja
koop face
das war wikipedia
aufgemacht
koop face
ok
ok aber das stand jetzt in dem artikel auch drin
dass das irgendwie nur bis 2010
war
und solange habe ich den
ja aber solange habe ich den rechner noch gar nicht
das klingt logisch
was ein satz
diese probleme die in ihrem computer sind
sind wie ein koop face
was
ok das habe ich ihm gezeigt was ist koop face
ja
ok
90 minuten
was will er machen
ja ok also
ich lasse den rechner jetzt einfach stehen
und sie machen die arbeit ja
ich bin froh dass uns peta das jetzt mal richtig erklärt
wie man das richtig macht
moment
er hat doch nicht gerade erzählt also
mal davon abgesehen ja wir wissen alle es ist scam
aber
selbst in der scammer logik
ergibt es keinen sinn weil wenn er
noch jetzt koop face entfernt vom rechner
warum soll ich ihn dann 5 jahre
bezahlen um koop face zu entfernen
versteht wahrscheinlich nur peta selbst
ok und
oder lebenslang
mache ich dann eine überweisung oder
ok
ja
und schnapper
umsonst
das ist ja fast
no brainer
ok
ich sage mal ich kann
natürlich jetzt auch einfach hingehen und den rechner
einmal selber neu aufsetzen da ist ja jetzt
im moment nicht viel drauf
das würde ja eigentlich auch helfen
aber
mein internet ist
infiziert
also aber ich bin ja froh
zum glück zum glück ist nur
mein internet infiziert
stell euch mal vor wo wir hingekommen
wären wenn das internet mit koop face
infiziert wäre
ok und wenn ich einen virenschutz
drauf habe
wie bezahle ich das denn weil in der kreditkarte habe ich nicht
also wenn dann überhaupt nur
einmalig aber wie gesagt ich weiß ja nicht
wie wir das dann mit der bezahlung machen
online banking mache ich gar nicht
ok
der microsoft support lässt sich
per itunes karte bezahlen
seems legit
wer hat das noch nicht erlebt
dass dass ihr den support per itunes karte bezahlen müsst
das ist der unterschied davon
mit banküberweisung sollen sie bitte bezahlen
178 euro
ok
mit welchen mit welchen program arbeiten sie denn eigentlich
eigentlich
ok
Programmen auch in mehreren Computer installieren und mit Hilfe von diesen Sachen werden wir unsere Arbeit erledigen.
Wollen Sie mit Items bezahlen? 150 oder Banküberweisung? 100, 60, bitte.
Können Sie das Geld nicht von meinem Konto abbuchen? Geht das?
Natürlich, ich habe es ganz zurück buchen lassen.
Wir können diese Banküberweisung, Items karten oder online Banking.
Kurze Frage, wie ist das denn, selbst wenn ich jetzt sage, ich möchte das überhaupt nicht haben, kostet mich das dann jetzt trotzdem was?
Sie müssen das machen, Sie haben uns angerufen und Sie sind verpflichtet, weil Sie uns angerufen haben.
Sie müssen das machen, aber als eine Kindes, wenn Sie da sind, kann man sagen, ich bin eine Diagnostik-Experte. Sie haben uns so meistens mal angerufen, so werde ich Ihnen auf jeden Fall das empfehlen, diese Probleme zu bereinigen.
Okay, aber eigentlich möchte ich ja gar nicht, dass da irgendjemand auf meinem Rechner irgendwie sich Zugang verschafft und da kann ich ja auch einfach jetzt hingehen und den Stecker am Rechner rausziehen.
Oh nein, das geht auf keinen Fall.
Nein, Herr, diese solchen Sachen machen wir nicht, weil wir arbeiten hier nur für die Kundensuppe.
Und wenn Sie einmal bei uns registrieren, dann haben wir 100% sicher, dass wir arbeiten, nicht auf der Selle.
Und ich sage mal, ich habe einen Freund, der richtig viel Ahnung von Computern hat, das könnte ich den doch eigentlich auch machen lassen, oder?
Natürlich nicht.
Natürlich, das können Sie auch gerne machen, aber wissen Sie, die Probleme, die in Ihrem Computer gibt, gibt es gefeiligte Probleme und die gehören zum Microsoft Corporation.
Einfach was?
Unsere Techniker haben eine Eigen-Technik, um mindestens eine Print-Pairing-Order 6-jähriger Erfahrung, um diese aller Probleme zu bereinigen.
Okay, wenn Sie jetzt sagen, Sie haben so viele, also so sehr erfahrene Mitarbeiter, was haben die denn für Zertifizierungen?
Wie bitte?
Was haben die für Zertifizierungen?
Herr Agentress, unsere Techniker sind agentress, kann man sagen, zertifiziert von Windows.
Zertifiziert von Windows, krass.
Zertifiziert von Windows würde ich auch gerne mal werden.
Und wissen Sie was?
Was wir geben Ihnen, was Windows oder Microsoft oder so die Gross-Up-Women bieten, die gleiche Programme und so weiter, benutzen wir auch in Ihrem Computer zu arbeiten.
Okay, also ich glaube, ich möchte da erstmal, ich möchte da erstmal einen Freund von mir drauf schauen lassen, dann würde ich sagen, wenn das wirklich nicht klappen sollte, dann kann ich Sie ja nochmal anrufen, oder?
Wie bitte?
Ich würde jetzt erstmal meinen Freund das reparieren lassen und wenn der das nicht schafft, dann würde ich mich nochmal bei Ihnen melden, ist das in Ordnung?
Was kommt jetzt? Da kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Nein, das ist nicht in Ordnung, verstehen Sie das?
Das ist jetzt ein anderer Typ.
Dann Sie haben diese Probleme und diesem Computer hat weniger Zeit, die kaum Zeit.
Wissen Sie, wenn Sie zu diesen Freunden gehen oder mit Freunden reparieren wollen, ist dann alles kaputt.
Alles kaputt?
Verstehen Sie das?
Ja, wenn alles kaputt geht, ist nicht schlimm, so viel ist auf dem Rechner nicht drauf, den Rechner kann ich auch neu aufsetzen.
Verstehen Sie, aber dieser Computer ist einzeln eine wichtige Rolle in unserem Leben.
Jetzt müssen Sie ihm überhaupt noch erstmal erklären, dass es sogar wichtig ist, nicht, dass er auf die Idee kommt, es einfach sein zu lassen.
Verstehen Sie das?
Verstehen Sie, haben Sie es jetzt endlich verstanden?
Das geht kaputt bedeutet, das Weg geht kaputt bedeutet, alle Teile gehen kaputt.
Das geht kaputt bedeutet, alle Teile gehen kaputt.
Endlich mal jemand, der sich auskennt.
Alle Teile gehen kaputt, Sie können das nicht neu aufbauen, Sie können das nicht neu aufbauen.
Aber ich habe doch eine Sicherung, die Sicherung ist in Ordnung.
Welche Sicherung Sie haben?
Ich habe alle meine Daten, die ich auf dem Rechner habe.
Der Typ hat das auch noch im Hintergrund, nee, hat das nicht im Hintergrund, nee, der hat es unten hier eingeholt, der hat hier G-Data, hat da unten der Taskleiste auf.
Die habe ich gesichert.
Aber Herr Sehen Sie, das ist nur 150 Euro, verstehen Sie einmal.
Mit diesem Kosten Sie können diese Computer ganz einfach, ganz einfach, ganz einfach in Zukunft benutzen.
Wie machen wir denn jetzt an der Stelle weiter?
In Zukunft?
Also ich habe mich jetzt eigentlich entschieden, ich möchte da erstmal einen Freund drauf schauen lassen.
Und wenn dann die Sachen wirklich noch alle kaputt sind, dann würde ich Sie einfach nochmal anrufen.
Herr, sagen Sie mir, wenn Sie eigene Bekannten haben, warum haben Sie uns angerufen?
Weil es da stand.
Weil in der Meldung drin stand, dass man anrufen soll.
Warum haben Sie unsere Nummer in dieser Meldung, warum haben Sie unsere Nummer bekommen?
Wir haben diese Meldung von Windows bekommen, dann Sie haben unsere Nummer bekommen, richtig?
Das ist richtig und da stand drin, ich soll anrufen.
Ja, ich möchte fragen, warum haben Sie nur unsere Nummer bekommen?
Oh, jetzt komm.
Ich erkläre.
Jetzt?
Sie haben nur unsere Nummer bekommen, weil wir Silverroom-Partner von Windows sind.
Okay.
Dann Sie, weil wir dieser Problem für Sie bereinigen, dann Sie haben unsere Nummer.
Wenn Sie eigene andere Probleme haben und Windows macht hier das Cash-Pay dieser Computer, dann Sie bekommen eine neue Nummer.
Aber wenn Sie das einmal mit einer Firma machen, mit einem Silverroom-Partner machen mit Windows, dann Sie nichts bezahlen.
Was?
Will er uns jetzt sagen, er macht es jetzt kostenlos oder was?
Okay, aber wenn ich jetzt einen Freund von mir frage, dann bezahle ich ja auch nichts.
Kein Problem, dann vielen Dank für die Anruf.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag, okay?
Den wünsche ich auch, danke sehr.
Die Mode Verbindung ist noch an.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, der beleidigt ihn noch ein bisschen oder sowas.
Also nicht der G-Dater-Typ, sondern der Inder beleidigt ihn jetzt noch ein bisschen.
Guck, jetzt haben sie ihren ganzen Shit drauf gemacht und im Hintergrund haben sie das Ding verschlüsselt.
Ja, Fail.
Inder-Scam.
Der ist lustig, also wir gucken jetzt nicht an, aber der Channel ist gut.
Der hat ein paar Sachen drauf, da habe ich schon ein paar Sachen von ihm geguckt, der ist nice.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir können uns jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag indischen Call-Center-Scams angucken.
Eigentlich wollte ich auch noch ein bisschen Broggers machen, aber ich glaube, das lassen wir jetzt bleiben.
Also sagen wir so, wir haben jetzt 19.30 Uhr, eine halbe Stunde können wir uns noch was angucken, dann muss ich was futtern.
Wollen wir uns noch was angucken?
Wir gucken uns noch an, was passt denn?
Scammer vs. Hannah Montana Linux.
Okay, das müssen wir mal kurz gucken.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken, das klingt so abgedreht.
Das müssen wir mal gucken, das geht wahrscheinlich auch nicht so lang.
Moment, aus, off.
Das ist der erste, den ich kenne, der allen Ernstes Hannah Montana Linux installiert hat.
Hat der eine VM in der VM?
Der hat eine doppelte VM, der hat Windows 10, da drin hat er Windows 7 laufen und in Windows 7 hat er seine Hannah Montana Linux VM laufen.
Sicher ist sicher, einfach im Scam innen, da weiß man nie.
Brandon ist es jetzt.
Das müsste man eigentlich mal live, das müsste man eigentlich echt mal im Stream irgendwie machen.
Dann müsste man sich eine VM in der VM machen und dann beim Inder Support anrufen.
Mit irgendeinem Fake-Volpe-Nummer.
Ach, jetzt müssen wir das C&B machen.
Okay, anscheinend fängt alles ganz gleich an.
Jetzt macht er jetzt die VM auf und dann Fullscreen oder was genau hat er vor?
Ja, Internet Explorer eindeutig.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ich bin nicht sehr gut mit Computern.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das ist, ich gehe nie in meine Geschichte.
Okay.
Der Scammer merkt, dass er geskempt wird.
Ich habe einen Pop-Up bekommen, den ich nicht in meiner Geschichte zeigen kann, und ich weiß nicht warum.
Der Scam-Typ hat echt Probleme, sein Linux zu bedienen, da kriegt es nicht gebacken.
Okay.
Ich denke nicht, dass du sicher bist, was du darüber sprichst.
Bist du sicher? Bist du sicher, dass du weißt, was du darüber sprichst?
Ich meine, komm schon, du sagst mir, dass du die Sicherheitsversorgung aufbauen musst.
Ah nein, jetzt hat er ihn entlarvt, das ist ja langweilig. Ich dachte, der Inder klickt noch ein bisschen rum und...
Der Clip von Silent Pain.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt nochmal an.
Okay, den gucken wir jetzt nochmal an und dann, dann gehe ich was futtern.
Okay.
Do not click on redeem. Do not click on redeem. Once you're done, after typing the number, you say me, I am done.
What?
Das hat irgendwie einen komischen Voice-Changer, das geht mir immer voll auf den Sack, wenn Leute Voice-Changer haben.
Once you're done with the alphanumeric number, say I am done, okay?
Oh, okay.
I am done.
Moment, was?
Oh, madam, madam, okay.
Moment, das verstehe ich nicht, da muss ich die Sache drum herum verstehen, warum tippt der Scammer den Kram denn da ein?
Die App heißt bestimmt nur 500.
Okay.
Tja, da ist er immer ein bisschen sprachlos.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Fake-Google-Store oder sowas.
Das ist lustig. Den kenne ich gar nicht.
Das sagt mir überhaupt nichts, der Channel.
Ich finde, da muss ich mal gucken, der hat bestimmt noch mehr coole Zeug, habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Aber es gibt eh viele lustige Scam-Videos, wo die Scammer gescampt werden am Ende.
Ja Leute, also irgendwie, 2,5 Stunden online gewesen, absolut nichts gemacht heute, absolut gar nichts.
Mal gucken, gibt es jemand hier, der online ist, der man hosten kann?
Ähm, hopp.
Der Rayst ist aber auch sauer, sauer aktiv hier.
Der Name sagt mir nur was, weil der hatte mal irgendwas, glaube ich, irgendetwas auch gemacht.
Linux weiter einrichten, ah, wen haben wir da?
Diese Pop-Ups, die gehen mir auf Twitch so ultra auf den Sack.
Moment, was? Schneewittchen und die sieben Geilen, nee.
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler, Einzuschauer, wieder 3D-Printer.
Es gibt in Deutschland nichts unter Science und Technology.
Es ist ja kein Wunder, dass ich immer Viewer kriege.
Monka BWL.
Kein Wunder, dass ich immer Viewer kriege, ist ja sonst keiner da, so quasi alternativlos.
Ok Leute, ich muss unbedingt was futtern, ich habe mega Hunger.
Äh, wir sehen uns morgen. Mal gucken, wahrscheinlich sehen wir uns morgen.
Ähm, bis denn, macht's gut, CU.
Moment, erst mal gucken.
Leute, wartet mal, gucken, ich glaube ich habe Prime-Subscriber vergessen.
Ich habe Prime-Subscriber vergessen.
Recent Events.
Nee, habe ich nicht vergessen, hu, gut.
Ja, aber man kann bei der Gelegenheit noch mal Sellout machen.
Übrigens, falls ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt.
Amazon Prime ist ja verbreitet, wer hat heute eigentlich keinen Amazon Prime-Account?
Könnt ihr euren Amazon Prime-Account kostenlos mit eurem Twitch-Account verknüpfen.
Und da bekommt ihr quasi monatlich kostenloses Twitch Prime-Loot.
Und ihr könnt einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Sub unterstützen.
Das Ganze kostet euch nichts und das Streamer hat alle Vorteile.
Davon, die ihr von einem normalen Sub kriegen würdet.
Ohne, dass ihr da was extra für bezahlen müsst.
Das ist nicht nice. Twitch Prime, beste.
Dauerwerbesendung.
Ja, zum Schluss kann man noch mal eine Runde Sellout machen.
Okay Leute, genug Sellout gemacht.
Und jetzt echt was essen, ich habe übeles Hunger.
Machts gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.